So, Pog. Leute, weiter geht's.
Headset entknoten. Oh, bye. Bin ich zu faul, ich lass es einfach so.
Gucken, solange nichts runterfällt. Ja, heute geht's weiter mit Proxmox bzw. mit
das hier jetzt. So. Genau, mit Proxmox. Und zwar, wir sind
gestern stehen geblieben bei dem Versuch, ein HA-Cluster-Setup zu erstellen, ohne ein
Tutorial gelesen zu haben von Proxmox. Also insofern, kein Plan. Ne, hab ich nicht ausprobiert.
Ich hab's gerade erst eben wieder gesehen. Ich hab's mir aufgeschrieben, aber ich hab's
nicht gesehen, bevor ich den Stream angefangen hab. Also wir haben das letzte Mal den Installer,
den Text-Installer ausprobiert, der tatsächlich ganz gut funktioniert. Das ist 1-to-1 der
normale Installer halt mit Text-Interface. Gibt keinen Unterschied. Danke für den Sub.
Wo wir gerade dabei sind. Leute, bevor der Stream richtig angelaufen ist, wisst ihr,
wir schmeißen schon mal kurz die Installation an von dem dritten, von dem dritten Node.
Hier, Custom, Later, Next, Next, ach, keine Ahnung, 4, weiß nicht, was ich dem gegeben hab, 4, 16G,
soviel brauchst du es sehen hat, 16G, Bridge, Networking, Next, Next, Next, Create, New Virtual Disk,
eine Ahnung, 50, Next, Next, Edit, Printer, so als dürfen wir nicht vergessen, bei CPU-Nested-Virtualisierung
einzuschalten und wir müssen noch UEFI einschalten, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe. UEFI, so,
und noch das Proxmox-Image-Mounten. Okay, da können wir nämlich einfach die Installation
schon mal anschmeißen, bevor der Stream richtig losgeht, weil wir brauchen das Ganze, weil soweit
ich das mitbekommen habe, kann man einen High-Availability-Cluster nur ordentlich betreiben
in Proxmox mit drei Nodes, was ja irgendwie auch sinnvoll ist und auch das automatische Migrieren
der VMs sagt zumindest der Chat und wir wissen ja, der Chat, der weiß sowas prinzipiell ja immer.
Chico! Moment, Sekunde, meine Katze will irgendwas. Chico, was siehst du? So, wieder da. Also anscheinend
geht Installer echt das erste Mal immer nicht, das ist sehr weird. Na gut. Ja, das habe ich
gestern, das hat gestern ja schon jemand laufend rumgespammt, vielleicht sogar du, ich weiß nicht
mehr im Chat, aber wir machen lieber drei Nodes, das kostet uns doch auch als VM überhaupt nichts,
ist doch wurscht. So, mal kurz andere Background Musik, was haben wir hier? SongSmiles,
happy and upbeat, jawoll. Extremly happy, dass wir virtualisieren dürfen. Welch ein Privileg,
wir dürfen virtualisieren. Da kann man eigentlich die Playlist volle Pulle machen. Eigentlich ist es
Mist, das ist ja übrigens, Leute, es ist ja bei jedem, es ist ja eigentlich bei jeder
hochverfügbaren Technologie so, dass du eigentlich immer drei Nodes brauchst. Das
habe ich auch schon bei Loadbalancer und sowas öfters gesagt. Alternativ gibt es manchmal noch
die Möglichkeit, verschiedene Wege zu benutzen. Also zum Beispiel, nehmen wir mal den Fall
Loadbalancer mit ClusterIP oder sowas, ja. Da ist auch am besten, man hat drei. Man kann,
wenn man ganz viel Geld sparen will, auch theoretisch sowas mit zwei machen, aber man
sollte immer sicherstellen, dass sie dann ein eigenes Interconnect-Kabel haben oder ein gemeinsames
Storage, worüber sie sich austauschen können. In irgendeiner Art und Weise musst du noch mal
extra sicherstellen, dass du nicht zwei Master hast, wenn mal kurz das Netzwerk ruckelt. Also
wenn du wirklich Geld sparen willst, no supported hardware acceleration. Was? Willst du mich verarschen?
Das habe ich doch eben eingeschaltet. Was ist das? Der will mich rollen, Alter. Hä? Hä? Chat, Chat,
Chattke, ihr wart doch eben dabei. Ich habe das doch eben im Installer schon angeklickt. Sag mal,
oder bin ich, oder Boomerbrain am Start? Das habe ich 100% schon angeklickt. Habe ich,
ne? Ja, ja. Lul. Keck W. Bug gefunden in VMware. So, wir schalten die anderen Dinger gerade schon
mal ein. Da haben wir unsere drei Nodes am Start. Hier lassen wir den Installer laufen. Der wieder
broken ist anscheinend. Ne, ne, ne. Geht. Ich weiß auch nicht, was das für Schmerzen hat. Gleich
wegen was? Weil, weil er die Option nicht akzeptiert hat. Ja, das ist, das sollte schon
wirklich kurz vor der Anzeige sein, denke ich. Gut, Passwort 123456. Kommt nie jemand drauf. Mail,
mail at kapalul.com. So, und da können wir uns ein bisschen, da können wir ein bisschen schwätzen,
während das installiert. So, pve-3. Ich, ja, irgendwie so. Ich glaube, der muss einfach nur
Unique heißen. Install. Okay, jetzt installiert er. Ja, Chat, was gibt's Neues? Irgendwas Spannendes,
was ich heute verpasst habe? Erst mal kurz schauen. Was haben wir denn? Erstes Solardach
über Autobahn fast fertig. Okay, und da kommen die ersten wahrscheinlich gleich schon an und
machen es kaputt. Wer hat weniger Humor im Büro? Boomer oder ein Jungspund? Boomer vs. Sumer gibt's
jetzt auch schon. Wisst ihr was? Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, dass es die beiden, dass es beide
Generationen von den jeweils anderen denken, weil die sich einfach nicht verstehen, humormäßig. Es
gibt, das sieht man doch schon an meiner Generation. Leute, überlegt mal, wie viele, jetzt mal, jetzt
mal ernsthaft, ernsthaft gefragt. Was denkt ihr von, sagen wir von 100, von 100 Leuten zwischen 35
und 40, die wirklich jetzt so in meinem Alter sind? Wenn du die fragen würdest, was ist das
bessere Lach-Emote? kekw oder lulw? Was meint ihr, wie viele von 100 wüssten überhaupt, wovon ihr
sprecht? Ich glaube, die meisten würden eher den machen. Und was sagen sie dazu, lulw oder lulw vs. kekw?
Was meint ihr, wie viel von 100? Also, also einer, wenn es hochkommt. Es ist nicht lolw, es ist lulw.
Guck mal, wir müssen jetzt mal, das kann nicht sein, wir müssen mal die Bildungslücke schließen.
Also, es gibt lulw, das ist ein Lach-Emote und es gibt kekw, das ist auch ein Lach-Emote. Jetzt ist
natürlich die Frage, was ist das bessere Lach-Emote? Und dann stellt sich eigentlich die, also die
eigentliche Frage ist lulw vs. kekw. Und es gibt ganz viele Leute, die sagen, es ist kekw mittlerweile.
Ich persönlich bin der Meinung, lulw ist immer noch das Beste, aber kekw hat eindeutig die
Vorherrschaft auf Twitter übernommen. Welches ist älter? Lulw ist älter. Und wisst ihr, was das
Tragische ist? Man glaubt es gar nicht, beide sind tot mittlerweile auf dem Emote. Die leben
beide nicht mehr. Das ist TotalBiscuit, das war ein englischsprachiger YouTuber, ein Influencer,
der ungefähr in meinem Alter war und an einer seltenen Krebssorte gestorben ist, an einer seltenen
Krebsart, den hat es richtig, richtig scheiße erwischt. Das ist TotalBiscuit und das ist
ElRicitas. Das ist ein spanischer Komiker, kann man glaube ich sagen. Der war eine ganze Ecke
älter, aber der lebt auch nicht mehr, der ist auch vor zwei Jahren oder so gestorben. Also beides,
beides, sowohl lul, die Leute hinter lulw, als auch kekw leben nicht mehr. Es gibt übrigens auch
ein sehr schönes, um die Bildungslücke weiter zu schließen, wir gucken uns das jetzt nicht an. Es
gibt auch ein sehr schönes YouTube-Video dazu, nennt sich kekw vs lulw und der Anfang ist eigentlich
prinzipiell schon, die ersten paar Sekunden müssen, müssen einfach sein, die sind schon einfach top.
Reicht schon. Also wenn du deine Bildungslücke schließen willst, kannst du dir angucken die
Story von lulw vs kekw, dann weißt du Bescheid. Also ich bin der Meinung, lulw ist immer noch das
bessere Emote. Ne, ist das ein Emote? Das ist irgendein sehnloses Emote. Heute ist mir wieder was
ulkiges, soll das glaube ich heißen. Das ist auch ein Wort, was keiner mehr verwendet im Jahr 2023.
Alter, was ulkiges. Okay, was ulkiges passiert in der Jobsuche. Öffentlicher Dienst ist ja echt
komisch. Gibt Arbeitszeugnis von Arbeitgeber oder werde ignoriert. Was? Hä? Moment, was? Gibt Arbeitszeugnis
von Arbeitgeber oder werde ignoriert. Naja, kannst ja auch ein vorläufiges, äh, Vorläufiges. Naja, die sind, die
sind wir. Also ich kann, ich kann euch sagen, wie das bei mir ist. Die, die waren da auch super korrekt mit, mit
Arbeitszeugnis und sowas. Ich musste das auch, ich musste das auch abgeben. Allerdings nicht direkt zur
Bewerbung und zum Vorstellungsgespräch. Vorstellungsgespräch hatte ich dann was Vorläufiges immer dabei, weil es
es gerade ergeben hat. Aber ich musste und das ist halt Vorgabe, wegen Geldwäsche und allem möglichen. Ich musste
am ersten Arbeitstag, ich musste ein Zeugnis mitbringen. Und das Geile war, ich hab's euch glaube ich schon
mal erzählt, mein alter Arbeitgeber hat es nicht rechtzeitig fertig gekriegt, das Zeugnis. Obwohl die mir
500 mal garantiert haben, es wird rechtzeitig fertig. Ich, also ohne Scheiß, hätten die mich beim neuen
Arbeitgeber für drei bis vier Tage wieder heimgeschickt. So nach dem Motto, sie können wirklich erst anfangen,
wenn sie das Arbeitszeugnis haben. Dann hätte ich das denen in Rechnung gestellt, meinem alten Arbeitgeber.
Die, äh, einfach aus Prinzip. Ja, die, die paar Tage Verlust. Und da, da wäre ich so nur noch vor Gericht gegangen,
weil das hätt's echt nicht sein können. Aber es hat ja glücklicherweise alles geklappt. Äh, da gewinnt KekW,
muss ich keine Umfrage machen. Leider, leider. Ich glaube, es gibt mehr KekWer als LulWer. Ja. Also, hattet ihr
schon mal das Problem, dass ihr zu eurem Arbeitgeber gegangen seid und ein Arbeitszeugnis haben wolltet,
ein Zwischenzeugnis, und der hat gesagt, ja ne, sie haben ja da gar keinen Anspruch drauf, aber gibt nix.
Oder ihr wolltet gar nicht fragen, weil ihr keinen Anspruch drauf hattet. Eins von beiden. Ist euch das schon mal passiert?
Weil da kann ich euch, ich hab euch das zwar schon mal erzählt, da kann ich euch einen Ratschlag geben,
den mir mal einer der wenigen, einer unserer wenigen FiveHead-Consultants gegeben hat.
Es gab nicht viele Consultants, wo ich sagen würde, ey, das war richtig gut, dass die da waren, die hatten auch wirklich
Plan vor dem, was sie machen. Aber das war einer der wenigen FiveHead-Consultants, die wir hatten.
Ein Grund ist, dass du dich bewerben willst. Ja, vielleicht willst du das ja auch nicht sagen.
Ähm, ne, aber es gibt, es gibt mehrere Gründe, warum ihr ein Arbeitszeugnis beantragen könnt,
beziehungsweise ein Zwischenzeugnis. Eines davon ist zum Beispiel Führungskräftewechsel.
Wenn jetzt grad ne Führungskräftewechsel, es bezieht sich soweit ich weiß übrigens nicht nur auf eure direkte
Führungskraft, also vielleicht ergibt sich das, aber es gibt eine Sache, da kann wohl die Personalabteilung fast nicht
rein sagen, und zwar, das ist, wenn ihr sagt, euer Aufgabengebiet hat sich geändert, weil die werden sicherlich
nicht anfangen zu diskutieren, das stimmt doch gar nicht. Dann sagst du, ja stimmt's ja wohl. Und dann, und wenn
sich das nicht geändert hat, wir arbeiten in der IT, Leute, unser Aufgabengebiet ändert sich wöchentlich.
Und die Themen, mit denen wir zu tun haben. Also kannst du davon ausgehen, wenn du seit ein, zwei Jahren kein
Zeugnis mehr hattest, du machst, irgendwas hast du auf jeden Fall neu gemacht, das ist rechtfertigt. Und außerdem
wird deine Personalabteilung dafür nicht anfangen zu diskutieren. Und das hat mir eine unserer Consultants mal
als Tipp gegeben, und das klang auch alles sehr einleuchtend. Also, wenn ihr ein Arbeitszeugnis haben wollt, ein
Zwischenzeugnis, und die Personalabteilung sagt, jo ne, gibt doch keinen Grund, da sagt ihr doch Aufgabenwechsel,
also, meine Aufgaben im Job haben sich geändert. Das scheint wohl gut zu hören, sagen Leute, ja. Das scheint wohl gut
zu funktionieren. Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie lang mein alter Arbeitgeber für mein letztes Zwischenzeugnis gebraucht hat?
Also nicht für mein Abschlusszeugnis, sondern für mein Zwischenzeugnis. Wisst ihr, also ich hatte ja ein
Zwischenzeugnis beantragt. Wisst ihr, wie lang die dafür gebraucht haben? Das hat noch mein alter Chef geschrieben,
ursprünglich. Nicht der neue, der alte. Ja, und Jahr ungefähr haben die bei mir auch gebraucht. Ein Jahr! Stell euch das mal vor! Ein Jahr!
Ist doch eigentlich der absolute Witz, oder? Das war eh so ein ganz spezieller Laden, was diese, was die Personalabteilung
und, und solche, also, wenn wir die eigentlich ausgehen als Bank- und Finanzdienstleister, ja, hätten sie das hinbekommen,
aber nope. Unglaublich. Also der letzte Arbeitgeber, was das angeht, wirklich lahm. Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt auch
letztens das allererste 7-TV-Emote für den Channel hinzugefügt. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was, was habe ich denn
hinzugefügt? Ich wollte eigentlich nur gucken, ob, ach, das hier. Ich wollte eigentlich nur gucken, ob es geht.
Das hier habe ich hinzugefügt. Cyberbeef, danke für den Sub. Was auch immer es uns sagen soll. Oh, Geisterfahrer.
Warum wegen Geldwäsche? Also ich kenne die, also ich kann dir das erklären, aber ich kenne die gesetzlichen Vorgaben
dazu nicht so wirklich. Also, ich vermute mal, die sind, also Finanzdienstleister, nicht nur Banken allgemein, die haben ja
relativ viel Kontrolle. Und ich gehe davon aus, die müssen kontrollieren. Ich habe ja auch ein polizeiliches
Führungszeugnis und alles mögliche gebraucht. Ich denke mal, die müssen kontrollieren, dass du nicht quasi irgendwie
ein halbes Jahr in Kolumbien oder sonst wo warst und hast mit Drogen gedealt in der Zwischenzeit und sowas.
Das heißt, die wollen schon sehen, dass der Arbeitgeber, wo du jetzt gesagt hast, dass du zuletzt gewesen bist,
auch wirklich der ist, wo du gewesen bist. Verstehst du? Weil ich könnte ja viel erzählen, wenn der Tag lang ist.
Ich könnte sagen, ich habe da und da gearbeitet und ich habe halt ein Arbeitszeugnis von vor eineinhalb Jahren
und kein aktuelles. Und in der Zwischenzeit habe ich irgendwelche kriminellen Sachen gemacht oder so.
Also kann ja alles sein. Ich glaube, das ist einfach Vorgabe, dass sie das machen. Also du brauchst das Arbeitszeugnis
vom letzten Arbeitgeber und ich gehe davon aus, dass sie dann halt auch gucken, dass du nicht irgendwie eineinhalb Jahre
sonst wo abwesend warst im Ausland und hast da nicht erklärbare Dinge getrieben und sowas.
Wie gesagt, ich musste auch ein Führungszeugnis vorlegen und die waren auch tatsächlich sehr kritisch.
Die haben mich beim Vorstellungsgespräch, jetzt muss man sich echt mal vorstellen, die haben mich im Vorstellungsgespräch gefragt.
Ich hatte im Lebenslauf drinnen stehen, irgendwie, fragt mir nicht, ich weiß es aus dem Kopf gar nicht mehr.
Da stand drin sowas wie irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 2000 bis 2003 oder irgendwie sowas.
Irgendwie so um das Jahr 2000 rum. War da nicht richtig beschrieben im Lebenslauf.
Und da hat mich allen Ernstes der Mann, der von der Personalabteilung dabei gesessen hat,
hat mich allen Ernstes gefragt, hier sie haben so um das Jahr 2000 rum hier zwei Jahre nichts gemacht.
Was war denn da?
Was?
Was weiß ich?
Keine Ahnung.
Das weiß ich doch jetzt nicht mehr.
Okay, doch, ich wusste, ich wusste was es war.
Und ich hab dann auch eine sinnvolle Antwort drauf gegeben.
Und ich hab erstmal gesagt, boah, keine Ahnung, das ist aber doch ganz schön lang her.
Also, die ehrliche Antwort wäre gewesen, ich hatte keinen Bock zu arbeiten und hab MMO Kreiselgrind 24-7 gemacht und wollte nix arbeiten.
So, das wäre die ehrliche Antwort gewesen.
So, direkt, direkt nach der Schule hatte ich keinen Bock zu arbeiten und dann Kreiselgrind 24-7 MMO spielen.
Das war die ehrliche Antwort. Das hab ich da natürlich nicht gesagt.
Und ich hab was gesagt, was auch nicht ganz falsch ist.
Sondern, dass ich damals bisschen mitgeholfen hab im Onlineshop von meinem Vater und, und, ja, so Dinger gemacht.
Ich hab ja schon die ein oder anderen Sachen gemacht, aber im Prinzip hab ich 24-7 Kreiselgrind gemacht.
Morgens aufgestanden, MMO eingeloggt, Kreiselgrind, abends ins Bett gegangen.
Kreative Auszeit, ja.
Mit der Berufsmasse, oh, nee, das, das war tatsächlich ein bisschen später.
Nee, nee, nee, das mit dem Arbeitsamtkurs, das war ein bisschen später.
Aber auch nicht so viel später.
Das war ein bisschen später.
Das war im Anschluss danach.
Ich hab ja dann irgendwann noch Zivildienst gemacht.
Das gab's ja damals noch.
Nee, das war ein Shop auf Ebay.
Der hat dort, ähm, ja, Kleingraben verkauft, alles mögliche.
Der hatte einen Onlineshop und hatte auch einen Ebay-Shop.
Hatte dort alle möglichen Dinger gekauft.
Also, mein Vater hat im Prinzip damals das gemacht, was heute der heiße Shit ist, wenn du in irgendwelche Coachinggruppen gehst.
Der hat zwar kein Dropshipping gemacht im eigentlichen Sinne, weil damals gab's noch kein Dropshipping.
Der hat aber Sachen billig eingekauft.
Irgendwelche Restbestände oder China-Chinesen-Sachen damals schon.
Und hat die auf Ebay Deutschland verkauft.
Und das war eigentlich keine schlechte Geschäftsidee damals.
Weil der ist dadurch nicht reich geworden.
Und das Geld ist mittlerweile auch alles wieder weg.
Aber die, die, die Geschäftsidee war an sich gar nicht, gar nicht schlecht.
Nur nicht betrug, der hat schon reingeschrieben, was da Sache ist.
Weil China-Chinesengraben da billig war.
Ja, da hab ich ein bisschen mitgemacht.
Aber ich mein ernsthaft, überlegt euch mal.
Wenn ihr in einem Vorstellungsgespräch sitzt, selbst mit 38 Jahren.
Und ihr werdet gefragt, was ihr vor 20 Jahren da gemacht habt, weil euer Lebenslauf da komisch aussieht.
Selbst dann werdet ihr nicht sagen, naja, ich hab einfach 24-7 MMO gespielt und hatte keinen Bock zu arbeiten.
Auch wenn's die ehrliche Antwort wär.
Das macht sich im Vorstellungsgespräch nie gut, auch wenn das 20 Jahre her ist.
Also hab ich schon die Wahrheit erzählt, allerdings das mit dem MMO-Kreisequant hab ich halt ausgelassen.
Ja, viele von euch sind noch nicht mal 20, aber die meisten schon.
Ich glaube, die meisten sind über 20 schon.
Also ich muss sagen, das war bei mir gar nicht so schlimm.
Das hatte gejuckt, das hatte gejuckt.
Ich versteh's aber ein bisschen.
Wie gesagt, das ist ein großer Finanzdienstleister in Frankfurt.
Und die haben ja auch rechtliche Vorgaben.
Also auch Behörden und so, die denen richtig auf den Keks gehen und sowas.
Und die müssen ihre Bewerber, glaube ich, sorgfältig durchleuchten.
Und es wäre fatal, wenn rauskommt, ey, vor 20 Jahren hat irgendeiner Drogenhandel betrieben.
Illegal über einen Online-Shop oder sowas.
Gut, ich mein, ja, letztendlich, ich musste ja auch ein Führungszeugnis abgeben.
Wobei ich gar nicht weiß, wie lange das gültig ist.
Wie lang steht denn sowas in einem Führungszeugnis?
Leute, wie lang steht denn ein Führungszeugnis überhaupt drin, wenn man irgendwelche Straftaten begangen hat?
Steht doch bestimmt nicht 20 Jahre drin.
Kommt das Bewerbungs- und Lebenslaufvideo noch?
Ja, ja.
Kommen wir auf die Straftat an.
Naja, zumindest, zumindest verstehe ich das, dass sie das so weit durchleuchtet haben.
Das ergibt schon irgendwie Sinn.
Ich hab ihnen halt nicht gesagt, 24-7 MMO gespielt und kein Bock zu arbeiten.
Ach ja, was ich hier sagen wollte, das war bei meinem alten Arbeitgeber nicht so.
Ich hab tatsächlich gesagt, ich brauche jetzt ein neues Arbeitszeugnis, weil ich mich bewerben will.
Hab ich gesagt, aber die wussten auch, dass es mir da auf den Keks geht.
Was haben sie auch gemacht?
Mein Zeugnis ist auch gut gewesen.
Ja.
Das, das, ähm, ist auch ziemlich gut.
Meinung zu Kik.
Hab ich ja letztens schon gesagt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass Kik sich durchsetzen wird als ernste Alternative zu Twitch.
Zumindest nicht in diesem allgemeinen Streaming für alle.
Gamestreaming.
Dass sich Kik durchsetzen könnte, was, sagen wir mal, im Bereich Gambling.
Also Sachen, die auf Twitch teil- und Sachen, die auf Twitch nicht erlaubt sind.
Und auch für Leute, die auf Twitch gebannt sind.
Kann ich mir vorstellen, dass sie auf Dauer diese Masse an Kohle in Streamer reinpumpen können.
Und den Share bezahlen können.
Gerade, wenn ihre Infrastruktur weiter wachsen muss.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, Infrastruktur kostet Geld.
Die müssen ja auch an AWS Geld bezahlen.
Und umso mehr Streamer die haben.
Und natürlich auch mehr Zuschauer.
Aber vor allem auch mehr Streamer.
Kostet auch sehr viel, sehr viel mehr Geld.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das aktuell verbrennen, die einfach quasi ihr Risikokapital, was sie bekommen haben.
Man darf nicht vergessen, hinter Kik steht ein Glücksspielbetreiber.
Also Betreiber von Glücksspielplattformen.
Wenn ich nicht ganz falsch liege.
Und letztendlich könnte denen ihr Ziel ja auch sein, gar keine ernste Alternative zu Twitch bauen zu wollen.
Sondern eine Alternative für Leute, die auch gerne Glücksspiel betreiben.
Also sprich, vielleicht so ein bisschen Leute, die sich auf Twitch nicht so wohl fühlen.
Und dass sie Kik eher so als Plattform aufbauen, wo es ein bisschen rauer zur Sache geht.
Und auch vielleicht das ein oder andere Platt nicht so vor den Mund genommen werden muss, wie auf Twitch.
Durchaus möglich, dass sie das in die Richtung probieren.
Aber als allgemeine Streaming-Alternative zu Twitch wird sich Kik nicht etablieren.
Gehe ich ganz stark von aus.
Und im Game-Streaming-Segment wahrscheinlich auch nicht als große Twitch-Konkurrenz.
Würdest du jemals dort streamen wollen?
Nee.
Nach aktuellem Maßstab nicht.
Ich meine nie.
Weiß ich, kann ich nicht sagen.
Wer weiß, wie das in einem halben oder einem Jahr aussieht.
Vielleicht ändert sich ja noch grundlegend was.
Aber nach aktuellem, so wie es aktuell sich die Plattform präsentiert, nicht.
Nee.
Ja, die sind teilweise lahmer als fuck.
Heh, okay.
CyberChef, danke für den Sub.
Blascht.
Ja, muss ich auch machen.
Hab ich letztens erst gemacht.
Leute, musstet ihr auch schon mal den Test machen, ob ihr die Kiste Sekt annehmen dürft oder nicht?
Alle, die noch nicht bei einer Bank oder bei einer größeren Versicherung sowas gearbeitet haben, werden jetzt den hier machen.
Ja.
Aber es gibt, du musst jährlich dort, oder Viertel?
Nee.
Zumindest jährlich.
Du musst jährlich so bestimmte Schulungen machen.
Und in diesen Schulungen kommen dann zum Beispiel Fragen vor.
Alter, Chelo.
Chelo will die Bann-Liste heute mal wieder anführen, glaube ich.
Oder die Time-Out-Liste.
Also, ihr müsst einmal im halben Jahr oder im Jahr, ich weiß nicht, ich glaube jährlich.
Ich glaube jährlich ist es.
Da müsst ihr so Fragebogen beantworten und Schulungen machen.
Da sind dann so Fragen wie zum Beispiel, ihr werdet von einem, was weiß ich, ihr führt ein Projekt durch, an dem auch externe Dienstleister beteiligt sind.
Einer der externen Dienstleister schenkt euch zum erfolgreichen Projektabschluss eine Apple Watch.
Dürft ihr die annehmen und sowas?
Da müsst ihr immer sagen, nein, die darf ich nicht annehmen.
Du darfst Geschenke nur annehmen, irgendwie, da gibt es irgendwie so eine Bezeichnung, so im üblichen Rahmen.
Und Veranstaltungen, die direkt halt Bezug haben zur Arbeit.
Also wenn die dich einladen beispielsweise zu irgendeiner Produktvorstellung nach Mallorca oder so.
Das ist theoretisch erlaubt.
Da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf, das ist aber erlaubt.
Also zu einer Produktvorstellung, die mit dem Projekt zu tun hat.
Also ihr präsentiert was und du wirst dann eingeladen.
Das ist okay.
Sie dürfen dir aber keine Apple Watch einfach so schenken.
Solche komischen Sachen musst du dann da ausfüllen.
Was der Test bringen soll?
Naja, dass du weißt, wenn dich einer bestechen will, dass du das nicht nehmen darfst.
Ich meine, das ist doch erstmal ein Anfang.
Und sag jetzt nicht, Chat, sagt jetzt nicht der gesunde Menschenverstand sagt einem das.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, bei vielen setzt der gesunde Menschenverstand aus, wenn einer ihnen sagt, ach willst du nicht eine Apple Watch haben.
Ja.
Und.
Dann musst du dann, dann musst du noch zum Beispiel, musst du so Security, zumindest ist das bei uns, das ist eigentlich total lustig, total lustig gemacht.
Und zwar, ähm, du musst so Security, Securityfragen beantworten.
Da stehen dann zum Beispiel so Sachen drin.
Äh, auf dem Gang begegnet ihnen eine Person ohne Zutrittskarte.
Wie gehen sie hier weiter vor?
So, so nach dem Motto, ähm, ist mir egal.
Ich fessle und knebel die Person.
Ich knebel die Person fest.
Ich haue ihr eine rein.
Oder ich sage unserer Securityabteilung Bescheid.
Oder sowas, ja.
Die, also, die Antworten sind meistens in diesen, das sind meistens Multiple Choice.
Die Antworten sind meistens so offensichtlich, dass du das kaum falsch machen kannst.
Kopfnuss.
Erstmal direkt weggeklatscht.
Erstmal eine reingeklatscht.
Zack.
So, so komische Fragen gibt es da.
Oder auch eine, auch eine, auch eine beliebte, auch eine Frage, auch eine Frage.
Äh, sie finden USB-Sticks auf dem Parkplatz.
Wie gehen sie hier vor?
So nach dem Motto, ich, ich schließe den USB-Stick umgehend an und versuche rauszufinden, wer den verloren hat.
Ähm, ich sage unserer Securityabteilung Bescheid.
Ich zerstöre den USB-Stick.
Äh, und okay, oder, oder ist mir egal.
So, irgendwie sowas.
So, also die, die Antworten sind so offensichtlich immer.
Hast du gehört, dass irgendwo solche USB-Stick explodiert sind?
Ne.
Was, was man am Fußgängerübergang macht, wenn es schneller gehen soll, Leerlauf rein und erstmal Gas geben.
Das hat, oh, das war die.
Leute, das war mal eine Situation mit meinem Opa.
Das letzte Mal war das, wo ich mit meinem Opa Auto gefahren bin.
Also nicht das letzte Mal, weil er gestorben ist oder so, kein Set getimed.
Sondern das letzte Mal, wo ich mit ihm Auto gefahren bin, bis er gapiert hat, dass es keine gute Idee mehr ist, in seinem Alter Auto zu fahren.
Und zwar, also, mein Opa hatte auch einen Schlaganfall, der konnte eh seine Hand nicht mehr richtig bewegen danach und sowas.
Zumindest, das war, wir, wir haben an einem, wir haben an einem Fußgänger, also wir haben an einem Zebrastreifen gestanden.
Und da ist eine Oma drüber gelaufen, über den Zebrastreifen, so richtig, so richtig langsam.
Und mein Opa ist irgendwie, fragt mich nicht, mit dem Fuß aufs, aufs Gaspedal gekommen.
Weil, wie gesagt, er hatte ein bisschen, nach dem Schlaganfall ein bisschen Probleme, so Hände und Füße hat er manchmal nicht so unter Kontrolle gehabt.
Ist er aufs Gaspedal gekommen und auf einmal, hast du richtig gehört, so das Auto aus dem, vor aus dem Stehen, auf einmal macht das Auto so richtig, so übelst hochgedreht.
Übelst laut und die Oma hat echt, ist fast so einen halben Meter zurückgesprungen, hat übelst Schiss gekriegt.
Und er hat dann halt noch irgendwie, und da war ein Leerlauf drin gehabt, der hatte ja eh eine Automatik und so.
Ist nix, ist nix passiert, ja, ist nix passiert.
Und meinem Opa war das peinlich, ja, zurecht, zurecht peinlich.
Und dann hat er gelacht, so nach dem Motto, mein Opa hat halt so gelacht, so nach dem Motto, ah, ah, ist mir das peinlich.
Und die Oma guckt halt in das Auto rein, in dem Moment, wo der gerade lacht und, und die Oma regt sich übelst auf.
So nach dem Motto, was die Oma gesehen hat ist, da sitzt ein alter Sack im Auto, der mich erschreckt hat und lacht mich jetzt auch noch aus.
Und ich hab da nebenan gesessen, hab mir gedacht, Alter, komm, hoffentlich ist das jetzt hier gleich vorbei, es geht weiter.
Die hat halt echt gedacht, der wollte, der wollte die trollen, so.
Ja, kann man machen. Man kann viel machen, aber ob man das machen sollte, ist halt die Frage.
Es geht doch gar nicht so darum, dass du das theoretisch auffaken könntest.
Es geht darum, bei, bei Vorstellungsgesprächen und gerade wenn du Auflagen von Behörden hast, dass du als Arbeitgeber, nennen wir es mal deine Pflicht, was du gesetzlich vorgeschrieben hast, erfüllst.
Ob das immer sinnvoll ist oder nicht, sei mal dahingestellt, aber wenn das Pflicht, verpflichtend ist, das zu machen, dann machen die das.
Es hat ja schon seinen Sinn, sich die Bewerber ordentlich anzugucken für solche Positionen.
Ja, als nächstes, oder erst ein Battle-Bit-Video, weiß noch nicht genau.
Ich setze ja Installer eigentlich durch, ja, Installer ist durch, okay, nice.
Aber denkst du, die hätten dich abgelehnt, wenn du gesagt hättest, hatte damals keinen Bock auf Arbeiten, wollte nur zocken?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber warum sollte man in einem Vorstellungsgespräch sowas erzählen?
Warum sollte man absichtlich was erzählen, was einen kacke dastehen lässt?
Macht doch eigentlich keinen Sinn, oder?
Wahrscheinlich wäre es ihnen egal gewesen, aber es hätte dann weitere blöde Diskussionen nach sich gezogen und es macht doch keinen Sinn.
Warum sollte man was Negatives über sich selbst erzählen im Vorstellungsgespräch?
Guck mal, du musst dir ja vorstellen, ein Arbeitgeber wird dir auch nicht irgendwelche, also auch wenn es gut wäre, aber die erzählen dir auch nicht irgendwelche blöden Sachen, ja?
So nach dem Motto, ach übrigens, ihr Windows-Notebook ist so vernagelt, dass sie eigentlich gar nichts drauf machen können.
Ist es positiv, eventuell denkt er, dass du ehrlich bist.
Nee, das ist nicht positiv.
So ticken Personaler nicht.
Weil, wenn man es sich betrachtet, ist niemand im Vorstellungsgespräch wirklich ehrlich, in beide Richtungen nicht.
Also, sowohl der Arbeitgeber ist nicht wirklich ehrlich, als auch der zukünftige, oder der Bewerber ist da nicht wirklich 100% ehrlich.
Die Kunst beim Vorstellungsgespräch ist eigentlich, durch Weglassen mancher Sachen, so nah wie möglich bei der Wahrheit zu bleiben und einen guten Eindruck zu machen.
Oder im Zweifelsfall auch durchs Ausschmücken nicht so großartiger Sachen.
Letztendlich, für mich lief es gut im Vorstellungsgespräch, ich musste mir weder großartigen Kram aus den Fingern saugen, noch wichtig tun, noch sonst was, weil meine Bewerbung, also mein Profil, hat halt einfach super auf die Stelle gepasst.
Also exakt das, was ich machen wollte, was ich machen kann, wo ich Erfahrungen drin habe, haben die auch gesucht.
Also das war halt wirklich schon ein ziemlich guter Match, würde man da jetzt auf Tinder oder so, oder was gibt es da sonst noch, Grinder oder sowas gibt es da auch noch, oder?
Sagen, und dementsprechend war das relativ easy.
Fange nächsten Montag eine Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker Anwendungsentwicklung bei einer Versicherung an.
Ah, guck mal, bist du auch bei einer Versicherung.
Wie sieht denn das Logo deiner Versicherung aus?
Vielleicht sind wir ja beide gleich.
Bei einer Versicherung in NRW an und musste auch Führungszeugnismehrunterlagen unterschreiben, dass ich x Straftaten nicht begangen habe.
Ja, ja, so ist es.
Also Leute, ich habe euch ja schon Storys aus meiner MMO-Zeit erzählt.
Ich will es jetzt nicht wiederholen.
Das ist teilweise heftigster Cringe.
Das hatten wir ja schon.
Das stimmt schon, aber mir ist die Seite und die Atmosphäre auf Twitch lieber.
Dass Amazon da Interessen hat, auf die ich wahrscheinlich keinen Bock habe, ja, das ist das eine.
Aber die Plattform an sich und die ganze, wie soll man sagen, die ganze Aufmachung und die Leute, die hier auf Twitch sind und die anderen streamen auf Twitch.
Ganz ehrlich, das ist mir viel lieber als das.
Wenn du auf Kick guckst, merkst du gleich, dass das irgendwie eine Gambling-Seite ist mit ein bisschen Gaming jetzt.
Aber das ist nicht dieses, nennen wir es mal, Family-Friendly-Streaming-Experience wie auf Twitch.
Was Twitch auch nicht überall ist, aber Twitch sich zumindest Mühe gibt.
Deswegen, ihr wisst ja, wir sind hier auch wirklich ein ganz streng christlicher Family-Friendly-Stream.
Und das ist Kick nicht.
Egal, wo du hinguckst, sind da irgendwelche super edgy Dinger am Start.
Ja, Notizblock, ich glaube, das trifft es ganz gut.
Ja, ah ja, diese Fragen kommen übrigens auch da drin.
Solche Fragen muss man da auch beantworten, ja.
So nach dem Motto, ist das ein besonders schützenswertes Geschäft und sowas?
Oder ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob es schützenswertes Geschäft heißt.
Ist es eine besonders schützenswerte Person?
Genau, handelt es sich bei diesem Geschäft oder sind an diesem Geschäft irgendwie besonders schützenswerte Personen beteiligt?
So nach dem Motto, das eine ist der Fußball-Nationaltrainer, das andere unser Bundeskanzler,
das andere, keine Ahnung, Emma aus der Personalabteilung und sonst was.
Ja, das musst du dann da auch bewerten.
Ja, oder sie entdecken regelmäßige Zahlungen nach Dubai.
Was machen sie damit?
Obwohl keinerlei Geschäftsbeziehungen nach Dubai bestehen, entdecken sie regelmäßige Überweisungen hoher Summen nach Dubai.
Wie gehen sie hier vor?
Solche Fragen sind in diesen Tests drin.
Das ist ganz furchtbar, Weird Champs. Seid froh, dass ihr das nicht machen müsst.
Aber ich kann euch sagen, so schwer sind die Dinger nicht.
Meistens sind die Antworten relativ easy und wenn nicht, man kann die Sachen auch mehrfach machen.
Wie gesagt, der Test soll bringen, dass du dich nicht bestechen lässt zum Beispiel.
Das wäre bei mir schon schwierig.
Also wenn mir einer unserer Dienstleister, dem ich theoretisch Vorteile verschaffen könnte in der Auftragsvergabe,
mir ein Geschenk kommt in 500 Euro.
Ich glaube, das wäre äußerst grenzwertig, ob ich das nehmen dürfte oder nicht.
Ich würde pauschal sagen, das ist zu viel. Das dürfte ich nicht nehmen.
Ganz streng nach Bestechungskram und sowas.
Gehe ich mal stark von aus, dass ich das nicht nehmen darf. Das ist über das übliche hinaus.
Zum Essen einladen wäre okay.
Ja, kommt drauf an.
Also was okay ist, wenn zum Beispiel ein Dienstleister sagt,
wir haben hier irgendwie Produktpräsentation und das Produkt ist wichtig für die Bank
und dazu gibt es auch was zu essen oder sowas.
Also wenn das einen Geschäftsbezug hat, das ist okay.
Genau, wenn das jetzt irgendwie zwei Jahre später ist und irgendwie eine Woche in irgendeinem Luxusskigebiet in der Schweiz beinhaltet,
dann wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Plus Essen.
Also es kommt wirklich auf den Kontext an.
Du musst immer gucken, ist das irgendwie bezogen mit der Arbeit und ist das irgendwie im normalen, üblichen Rahmen.
Und bin ich eigentlich so weit dran mit dem Chat?
What the fuck?
Jetzt gibt es ja schon USB-Bomben, Alter.
Genau so hat er ungefähr gelacht.
Haha, die Technik, was wir machen. Die Oma hat es aber ziemlich geschockt.
Was?
Ich arbeite seit drei Monaten für ein großes Systemhaus und ich hatte keinen Plan von dem Zeug, was sie machen.
Es ist hauptsächlich Azure und ich habe es in drei Monaten ziemlich schnell gelernt.
Ich verstehe den Kontext dieses Chat-Eintrags nicht, aber GG Eats.
Hat er es gestern überzeugt?
Ich muss sagen, bis jetzt finde ich es gar nicht schlecht für den Anwendungszweck.
Aber ich habe keinen Anwendungszweck daheim dafür.
Ich habe eine Frage beim Bewerbungsgespräch.
Wie würden Sie vorgehen, wenn ein User sich nicht einloggen kann?
Ja, das kommt drauf an, was da benutzt wird.
Mit Ja würde ich schauen, ob er gesperrt ist und ihm vorübergehend ein neues Passwort geben beantworten.
Hä, warum?
Also, okay. Ich sage dir mal, was ich da drauf sagen würde.
Natürlich immer ein bisschen im Kontext, was das für ein Laden ist.
Also, wenn ich diese Frage im Vorstellungsgespräch beantwortet würde, würde ich sagen, da fehlt mir der Kontext.
Ich weiß ja gar nicht, was es hier jetzt für genauen Vorgaben gibt.
Also, da müsste man sich den jeweiligen Prozess zum Zurücksetzen des Passworts angucken.
Man müsste natürlich auch kontrollieren, wer das ist.
Also, im Zweifelsfall auch nochmal gucken, gibt es den Typ wirklich oder ruft er von einer externen Telefonnummer an.
Also, sprich, gibt es irgendwelche Anzeichen, dass der einer bescheißen will.
Würde ja wirklich die Benutzernamen überprüfen.
Und am besten über das offizielle Passwort-Zurücksetzverfahren, was es dann eventuell gibt,
an dem ein neues Passwort zukommen lassen, was er sich selbst vergeben kann.
Wobei es halt die Frage ist, ob es das bei jeweiligen Unternehmen gibt.
Aber ansonsten, so verkehrt wird die Antwort...
Also, wenn das eine Antwort war, die ein bisschen in die Hose gegangen ist
und nicht hundertprozentig das ist, was die sich vorgestellt haben,
das wird wahrscheinlich nicht der ausschlaggebende Punkt sein.
Die Frage ist halt, wie du ihm das Passwort übermittelt hättest.
Per Telefon, ohne dass du überprüft hast, dass er das ist, ist vielleicht nicht so schlau.
Glücklicherweise habe ich das mit Endanwendersupport nichts zu tun.
Die kommen nicht zu sowas bei mir.
Wenn mich jemand anruft, oder wenn jemand was hat in der Richtung,
es ist irgendein Entwickler oder Leute, die ich kenne,
wo ich dann auch weiß, okay, die arbeiten hier und die brauchen Zugang,
dann kann ich sagen, hier, gib mal dein SSK-Key her,
ich schieb dich mal kurz auf den Server drauf.
Solange sich gerade Live-Umgebung ist.
Ja gut, das finde ich, aber klar, du bekommst die ersten sechs Monate
das gleiche Gehalt, was du danach auch bekommst.
Letztendlich wirst du die ersten sechs Monate nicht machen,
nicht alles machen können, komplett.
Aber gut, das müssen die halt einkalkulieren.
Können ja schlecht sagen, wir geben dir die ersten sechs Monate nur die Hälfte,
dann würde ich sagen, ihr habt sie nicht mal, ich fang doch nicht bei euch an.
Oder einmal ein halbes Jahr für die Hälfte.
Weil das ist ja auch mit Aufwand verbunden und Anstrengung,
sich einzuarbeiten, umso schneller, umso besser ich das hinkriege,
umso besser für die. Ich glaube, es geht los.
Also wenn wirklich mal irgendjemand auf die Idee kommen sollte,
man kriegt weniger Geld die ersten sechs Monate,
würde ich deinem Leben nicht anfangen.
Leider gibt es keine Freitextantworten.
Du kannst bloß Multiple Choice machen und am Ende dann auch das nicht abgeben,
nicht abschicken, wenn die Antworten falsch sind.
Also das Gesamtding. Also wenn zu viele Antworten falsch sind.
Ja, man kann die Fragen, genau, man kann die Fragepunkte so häufig machen, wie man will.
Ja, genau, solche Fragen habe ich auch beantworten müssen.
300 weniger, ja gut, in der Schweiz, ihr verdient ja auch 50.000 Euro im Monat.
Da sind 300 Euro auch nicht schlimm.
Danke für den Sub, Mr. Wali. Underscore.
Traue ich mich das anzuklicken? Ich glaube nicht.
Wer weiß, was das ist hier im Chat, gell?
Hat sich am Homelab was geändert? Bei mir daheim? Nö.
So, ich habe den Chat geschafft, sehr schön.
Nein, habe ich nicht, werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht machen.
Hast du schon mal Cubespray gearbeitet?
Nö, habe ich auch nicht vor. Ich weiß, was das ist.
Das ist so ein Ansible, also ein komplettes Ansible Playbook zum Kubernetes installieren.
Ich persönlich bin der Meinung, das braucht man heute nicht mehr.
So, also, dann würde ich sagen, Proxmox.
Wir machen mal so langsam aber sicher weiter.
50 Minuten geschwätzt, gutes Intro.
150 Leute am Start.
Was hältst du von Compose? Du meinst Docker Compose, oder was meinst du?
Oder Compose? Compose allein kenne ich nicht.
Ach ne, Convert your Docker. Ach doch, das kenne ich.
Habe ich aber noch nie benutzt.
Habe ich noch nicht benutzt, keine Ahnung.
Ich habe es mir angeguckt, ist nichts Geheimes.
Windows unknown.
Ich meine, immerhin funktioniert es ordentlich unter Windows, ja.
Gibt es eigentlich 2.023 Leute, die nicht wissen, dass Saturn...
Ja, gibt es. Ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Das war eigentlich schon vor irgendwie 150 Jahren bekannt.
Und die haben sich ja früher auch nur dem Show-Effekt in der Werbung ein bisschen gebieft.
Ja, das ist wirklich merkwürdig.
So, also, Leute, wo sind wir das letzte Mal stehen geblieben bei Proxmox?
Also, kann ich euch ganz kurz zeigen.
Wir haben 2, also wir haben einen Cluster, einen Proxmox Cluster aus 2 Nodes.
P4E1 und P4E0.
Da habe ich ein bisschen rumgebastelt mit lokalen Storages, mit ZFS Storage und mit ZEV Storage.
Das ist ein ZEV Storage, wobei ich dazu sagen muss, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung von ZEV gehabt davor.
Das heißt, die Oberfläche ist insofern schon mal ganz gut.
Das ist easy, ja.
Ob ich das jetzt gut konfiguriert habe und richtig gemacht habe, sei mal dahingestellt.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher.
Aber probieren wir mal aus.
So, und was ich gestern ausprobieren wollte, wo wir stehen geblieben sind, ist folgendes.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ich habe hier eine VM laufen.
Das ist eine...
Wie macht man das nochmal auf hier?
Konsole?
Konsole.
Alter, ernsthaft?
Das ist Debian.
Das ist ein anarchisches Debian.
Das können wir auch anpingen.
Ups.
Debian, hier.
Root.
IP add.
Guck, unser Debian hat... Ah, nee, 44 ist es jetzt.
44.
So.
Also das ist die IP von unserem Debian.
Was wir gestern schon gemacht haben ist,
das Debian selbst, das läuft...
Machen wir mal zu.
Ihr habt ja gesehen, dass das jetzt die IP ist.
Machen wir mal so.
Das Debian selbst,
das läuft auf
dem Ceph Cluster.
Hier sieht man es.
Hardware.
VM auf Kekl. Kekl ist der Ceph Storage.
Wie man hier auch sieht.
Und...
Was wirklich...
Was wirklich cool ist,
was man schon mit 2 Nodes machen kann,
ist Live Migration.
Also sprich, geht mal davon aus,
ihr wollt jetzt diesen Node hier runterfahren mit der VM drauf.
Aber ihr wollt nicht, dass die VM ausgeht.
Dann geht ihr einfach hier drauf.
Also das hier ist Server Nummer 1,
das ist Server Nummer 2. Das sind unterschiedliche Kisten.
So, die VM läuft aktuell hier drauf.
Dann kann ich sagen, Migrate.
Wir wollen es rüber schieben auf PVE 1.
Auf den anderen Node. Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Wie lange es dauert,
bis die VM rüber geschoben ist.
Achso, ist übrigens schon fertig.
Oder auch nicht.
Jetzt, fertig.
Gleich fertig.
Aber ihr seht, es gehen keine Pings verloren.
Und auch keine...
Hier, guck mal. Hier wurde es migriert.
Das hat 2 Millisekunden gedauert,
das Migrieren.
Von einem Node auf den anderen.
Also das ist schon mal sehr nice.
Geht allerdings auch nur mit Shared Storage.
Ja, und mit
mehreren Nodes. Und das coole ist,
es gibt auch, also das finde ich,
haben sie wirklich gut gemacht.
In
Proxmox. Also du hast mehrere Stufen
davon. Du kannst das Ganze mit
einem Cluster-File-System machen.
Also mit Cluster. Ceph ist ja nicht wirklich Cluster.
Mit so einem Shared-File-System
wie Ceph kannst du das machen.
Du kannst allerdings auch, wenn du nur
Local Storage hast, der
keine Ahnung, X4 formatiert ist.
Du kannst auch die Noob-Variante
davon machen. Du kannst Replication
einschalten. Dann wird die Disk
immer im Hintergrund alle 15 Minuten
von einem Storage auf den anderen
repliziert. Und sollte
sich der hier wirklich mal verabschieden,
kannst du die VM dann aus der Disk
recreaten auf einem anderen.
Ist aber nicht so schön, dass Ceph
integriert ist.
Ceph-FS muss man glaube ich sagen.
Integriert ist es viel nicer.
Also ihr habt es gesehen. Komplett
ohne Downtime wurde das Ganze
also fast schon, fast schon so gut
wie bei einem Kubernetes-Rolling-Update.
Nur dass es nach wie vor eine VM ist.
Also das kann man nicht wirklich vergleichen. Aber es ist gut.
Ist wirklich nicht schlecht. Also haben sie gut gemacht.
Unter der Haube
benutzen die anscheinend ziemlich
Standard-Linux-Tools, habe ich gesehen.
Es ist
zur Virtualisierung KVM.
LXC für Container.
Es ist DABD für
Netzwerk-Storage.
Es ist Ceph für Netzwerk-Storage, ZFS,
X4 Sachen für lokalen
Storage.
Wie heißt das?
Wie heißt dieses andere Ding?
NNB, ND oder so noch.
Also die Standard-Dinger, die man kennt.
Aber ordentlich
vorkonfiguriert.
Was mir bis jetzt nicht so gefallen hat,
sind wie man Settings daran macht.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man hier die...
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wo das war.
Ja, wenn man zum Beispiel
den Host-Namen umbenennen will,
dann muss man hier über das Web-Interface
so eine Host-Datei editieren.
Das ist schon ein bisschen weird.
Und jemand, der das noch nicht gemacht hat, wüsste wahrscheinlich
auch nicht, was er hier machen muss.
Also wenn ihr jetzt den Node umbenennen wollt,
dann müsst ihr nämlich hier den Host-Namen umbenennen.
Und euch per SSH einloggen und
auch ETC-Hostname umbenennen.
Also, das ist nicht so schön.
Vielleicht geht es aber auch anders.
Aber ich habe es in der Hilfe-Seite gefunden.
Die wollten, dass man sich per Shell einloggt.
Das könnte man ein bisschen schöner machen.
Das ist an sich bis jetzt echt nicht verkehrt.
Ich werde es aber trotzdem,
das kann ich auch sagen, egal wie erfolgreich
das Ganze jetzt hier heute verläuft,
noch mit dem dritten Node und sowas,
ich werde es daheim nicht benutzen.
Nicht, weil Proxmox schlecht ist,
sondern weil ich nicht den
Anwendungszweck bei mir daheim habe,
der den Proxmox erfüllt.
Proxmox ist hauptsächlich erstmal
ein bisschen was in Richtung
VMware ESX und WSphere obendruf
und, hast du nicht gesehen,
eine Virtualisierungslösung.
Also ein VM-Management-System.
Das habe ich aber
bei mir daheim
gar nicht als Hauptanforderung,
weil ich habe eine Single-Node-Kiste
und ein paar Raspberry Pis
im Haus, die anderes Zeug machen
und auf dieser Single-Node-Kiste
will ich mit relativ easy Web-Interface
VMs betreiben,
Container betreiben,
Storage betreiben,
Backup machen und alles mögliche.
Man kann sich das
ohne Probleme selbst bauen.
Aber das ist ja gerade das,
was ich daheim nicht mehr machen will.
Weil wenn ich mir das selbst bauen will,
könnte ich mir einfach ein Raw Ubuntu
oder ein Raw Debian auf die Ledungskiste hauen,
hatte ich ja auch jahrelang hier daheim.
Und mit Docker-Compose-Files
oder einem Single-Node-Kubernetes
oder was du nicht gesehen bauen,
würde auch alles funktionieren.
Mache ich aber nicht.
Und nachdem halt Virtualisierung
lohnt sich Proxmox für mich nicht so richtig.
Aber ich muss sagen,
das was ich gesehen habe hier
mit Cluster und Live Migration
ist easy Setup
und funktioniert auch gut.
Und das Ziel jetzt ist,
ich baue noch einen dritten Node dabei,
weil aktuell ist es so,
ich zeige euch mal was.
Was passiert, wenn dieser Node
hier, welcher ist denn das überhaupt?
Was passiert,
wenn dieser Node down geht?
2.31
Was passiert, wenn der hier down geht?
Dieser Node ist weg.
Auf dem läuft gerade die VM.
Normalerweise würde ich jetzt erwarten,
okay, ich habe einen Shared Storage.
Die VM wird automatisch
rüber migriert, wird sie aber nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht,
wenn man nur zwei Nodes hat.
Man braucht zwingend, es sei denn,
man macht irgendwelche komischen Konfigurationsdinger,
man braucht zwingend einen dritten Node.
Was streng genommen
auch Sinn macht,
weil, Chat, wer es Pfeil fährt,
was passiert bei einem Cluster
oder warum spricht man von einem Cluster
eigentlich erst ab drei Nodes aufwärts?
Was ist das Problem, wenn du
nur zwei Nodes hast in einem Cluster?
Oder sagen wir mal so,
das gibt mehrere Probleme.
Was ist das Hauptproblem,
wenn man ein Cluster hat mit nur zwei Nodes?
Ich kann euch übrigens auch mal
ein Beispiel aus der Praxis gleich erzählen.
Im Prinzip ist das
richtig, was ihr geschrieben habt.
Jetzt überlegt euch mal,
du hast jetzt hier
guckt die VM,
du kannst die auch nicht migrieren
und sonst was,
weil, weil
äh,
war der hier Master
vielleicht? Ah ja, hat ein bisschen
gedauert. Ja, guckt,
der ist jetzt komplett dead,
und da kannst du hier auch nix,
geht nicht, kannst du auch nix migrieren.
Obwohl, shared storage.
Warum das von Hand nicht geht, verstehe ich nicht.
Ich dachte, man könnte zumindest,
aber gut, der weiß halt nicht, ob der hier wirklich dead ist
und sowas. So, also,
ein Problem, wenn du ein Cluster
aufbaust mit nur zwei Nodes
ist, nämlich genau das hier.
Kann man sich jetzt erstmal nichts
darunter vorstellen, aber ich werde es mal kurz erklären.
Wir machen mal wieder,
wir machen mal wieder folgendes,
DrawIO.
Was jetzt Diagramms.net heißt,
was ein bescheuerter Name ist, jeder schreibt DrawIO.
So, also,
du hast jetzt hier zwei Kisten,
sagen wir mal Loadbalancer, okay?
Okay, äh, sagen wir mal,
du hast zwei Loadbalancer.
Ah, die war blau, okay.
Das ist LB1 und das ist LB2.
Und jetzt baust
du ein Cluster. Wenn du ein Cluster baust,
hast du dann,
machen wir mal irgendwie so
eine Wolke oder so.
So, wenn du ein Cluster baust,
hast du eine Cluster-IP. So was zum Beispiel.
122168, keine Ahnung,
44.1 oder so was.
So.
Und diese IP
muss ja am Ende
von einem der beiden Loadbalancer
auf der Netzwerkkarte konfiguriert sein.
Und irgendeiner der beiden
Netzwerkkarten muss auf ARP-Requests,
die reinkommen, antworten.
Kennst du das Boo von Edward Snowden?
Ne, kenn ich nicht.
Also, das ist Shared.
Oder nicht Shared,
ja doch, Cluster.
Cluster-IP nennen wir das mal.
So, aktuell ist es so,
dass
in der Cluster-Config,
die sich geeinigt haben,
dass das hier aktuell
der Masternode ist.
Und ich nenne das auch so,
falls wieder Leute getriggert sind,
da wissen die meisten einfach, um was es geht.
Das ist der Masternode.
Der hat aktuell auf seinem Netzwerkinterface
die Cluster-IP konfiguriert.
Und wenn es irgendwelche
ARP-Requests gibt,
who has diese IP,
dann antwortet der auch.
Was ich jetzt machen kann ist,
ich kann mich per Kommandozeile
da einloggen.
Ich kann mich da jetzt einloggen
drauf, auf dem Cluster.
Das ist mein Terminal hier, okay.
Und auf dem Terminal schreibe ich jetzt so was wie
switch oder sowas
oder takeover
und löse manuell
ein Befehl
ist jetzt manuell ein Befehl ab,
dass der Masternode
geschwenkt führt von LB1 auf LB2.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Die können ja, die sind ja
beide da, die können beide miteinander kommunizieren.
Wir machen das dann nochmal so.
Switch.
Ja, das ist jetzt ein Router, aber wir wollen jetzt mal nicht
nicht mehr
Disco förmlicher sein als notwendig.
So.
Also die
haben gemeinsames Netzwerk, das ist überhaupt
kein Problem.
Die können miteinander reden und die stimmen sich
jetzt ab und das heißt
LB2 macht jetzt hier takeover
als Master und dann ist
halt danach
der hier Masternode
und der hier nicht mehr.
So.
Und sobald es den nächsten
Uprequest gibt
kommen dann eben die Packages
hier raus. Ganz einfach.
So, aber
was
passiert jetzt,
wenn das Netzwerk wegfliegt?
Was passiert, wenn das Netzwerk wegfliegt?
Normalerweise
muss
jetzt entschieden
werden,
welcher der beiden Nodes Master wird.
Weil es sieht ja kaputt aus, ja.
Der Node sieht den nicht mehr
und denkt automatisch, ja okay, der andere
ist weg, ich muss Master bleiben.
Und der hier sieht,
oh, der andere ist weg.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt Master
werden, weil ja der andere Node,
der Master war, weg ist.
Das heißt, wenn du Pech hast,
wenn du Pech hast,
hast du dann, und dann
erscheint, dann sind die Netzwerk
Ruckler sind vorbei, ja.
Netzwerk Ruckler sind vorbei und auf einmal
hast du 2
2 LBs,
die auf einmal Master
sind, mit der IP.
Und das kann ja nicht so richtig funktionieren.
So,
das ist eines der Hauptprobleme, was du hast,
wenn du nur 2 Knoten hast.
Wenn man ganz viel
Geld sparen will, und ich kann euch, ich kann euch
das berichten,
und zwar
damals, als ich noch beim Provider
gearbeitet hab, da hatten die tatsächlich ein Setup
aus
2 Loadbalancern.
Was ist der Fachbegriff? Split Brain.
Das heißt wirklich so,
wie es der Chat geschrieben hat.
Gesplittetes Gehirn. Klingt ein bisschen
eklig, aber das nennt sich so.
Manche sagen auch Split Horizon,
gibt's auch, oder
ja,
gibt bestimmt noch ein paar mehr
Begriffe dafür.
Du hast auf einmal 2
Master Nodes und 2 DRP. So,
und jetzt kann ich euch mal
die Story erzählen.
Wo ich noch beim Provider
gearbeitet habe, hatten wir
exakt dieses
Problem.
Wir hatten hier
das so miteinander verbunden,
und ich weiß noch,
damals war es oftmals, also das war
ziemlich genau das Setup, was wir hatten.
So, und
es hat tatsächlich manchmal das Netzwerk geruckelt,
und
wir hatten dann Split Brain Probleme, aber was
viel problematischer war, und man hätte das
ja verhindern können,
man kann ja auch
so eine Art Interconnect bauen. Also sprich,
man schließt die Loadbalancer nicht
nur ans gemeinsame Netzwerk an, sondern
man verbindet die Loadbalancer
nochmal mit einem Interconnect untereinander.
Man legt quasi nochmal
ein Kabel zwischen den beiden Loadbalancern,
stöpselt die 2 zusammen,
und gibt dem nochmal
quasi so ein Interconnect-Netz.
Dann ist es nicht schlimm,
wenn die hier ruckeln. So.
Und das... Nein, Heartbeat machen
die auch so. Man macht wirklich ein extra
physisches Kabel.
Man baut noch eine zweite Netzwerkkarte
ein und steckt ein Kabel dazwischen.
Eigentlich müsste ich einen Pfeil machen, der
auf beiden Seiten...
Ich bin aber zu blöd, ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Ja, so.
Ja.
Also du ziehst hier wirklich noch ein Kabel,
und jetzt hast du
den Vorteil, okay, wenn das
wegfällt, sehen die sich noch hier drüber,
und wenn das wegfällt, sehen die sich noch hier drüber.
Und...
Das haben die sich damals
gespart, und wir hatten öfters
das Problem bei irgendwelchen Netzwerkrucklern
oder anderen Sachen.
Oder es sei ja auch nur, dass
einer von denen stark ausgelastet war und nicht rechtzeitig
geantwortet, was auch immer.
Da gab's Probleme. So. Es gibt jetzt
prinzipiell 2 Sachen. Das ist die Budget-Variante,
die Budget-Variante, die ich hier gezeichnet hab.
Man macht noch
ein extra Interconnect-Netz,
aber trotzdem schön ist das Ganze nicht.
Man kann sich jetzt vorstellen, es gibt noch
mehr Möglichkeiten, weil
Netzwerk ist ja nicht
das Einzige, worüber
sich so Cluster-Member
unterhalten können.
Es gibt auch die Möglichkeit,
dass die sich über ein gemeinsames Storage-Volume
unterhalten können.
Also man könnte beispielsweise auch noch hier
eine Shared-Disk
machen,
worüber sich die unterschiedlichen
Cluster-Member unterhalten können.
Wichtig ist eigentlich
nur,
dass es nie zu der Situation
kommen kann, oder sagen wir mal so, dass es
nicht so einfach zu der Situation kommen kann,
dass beide sich
nicht mehr sehen.
Weil dann hast du das Problem mit zweifachem Master,
weil jeder denkt, der andere ist kaputt.
So. Und um das wirklich
ordentlich zu machen, brauchst du
normalerweise drei Cluster-Nodes.
Ich meine, das ist auch relativ logisch, wenn man sich das hier anguckt.
Es gibt drei,
du hast drei Cluster-Nodes. Und nach Möglichkeit
verbindest du die auch mehrfach miteinander.
Weil dann hast du
immer noch einen Dritten,
der mitentscheiden kann, was er sieht.
Beziehungsweise halt, je nachdem.
Also wenn die sich jetzt nicht mehr sehen,
aber die sich über das Netzwerk noch den Dritten sehen,
also du hast
viel bessere Verbindungen
und du wirst dir
im Endeffekt irgendwo immer einig,
wer neuer Master werden soll.
Beziehungsweise was jetzt passieren soll.
Natürlich im Zweifelsfall,
wenn es ganz kacke läuft und alles weg ist
und so.
Aber das ist der Grund, warum du standardmäßig sagst,
ein Cluster sollte eigentlich mindestens
aus drei verschiedenen Knoten bestehen.
Und im besten Fall
sind diese drei Knoten oder zumindest
einer von den drei Knoten
noch an einem anderen Standort.
Disk. Das hier unten ist die Disk.
Ja. Am besten
ist, du hast noch einen zweiten
Standort oder vielleicht sogar einen dritten Standort.
Dann
machst du es richtig. Natürlich
irgendwelche Sonderfälle, dass das
mal eintritt, kann es immer geben.
Aber in der Regel bist du mit so einem Setup relativ
safe. So.
Und das ist das Gleiche, warum
Proxmox wohl sagt,
man braucht
drei Clustermember,
dass das Ganze
funktioniert mit automatischer
Migration. Und das werden wir jetzt mal
ausprobieren. Wir gehen jetzt mal hin. Cluster.
Äh.
Wo war das? Cluster.
Ne. Cluster.
Äh.
Sollten die jetzt nicht irgendwas anzeigen?
So von JoinInformation? Ach hier.
JoinInformation. Genau. Das brauchen wir.
Also neue
Nodes in Proxmox aufzunehmen
habe ich festgestellt, ist easy as
fuck.
Kopiert sich diese Clusterinformation.
So.
Lockt sich.
Gucken wir mal, was das Ding für eine
IP gekriegt hat.
141.
Lockt sich
auf dem zu joinenden
Node ein.
Mit super secure Passwort, mit best practice
Passwort.
Äh. Achso. Was haben wir gestern
noch gemacht?
Ähm.
Wir mussten doch noch ein paar Sachen umstellen, oder?
Repositories mussten wir noch
umstellen vorher.
Hm.
Wo war denn das?
Äh. Options?
Ne. Wo ist es denn?
Cluster?
Hä?
Ach hier. Nicht auf Datacenter. Hier
muss man hin.
Repositories. Genau.
So. Dann haben wir das Repository
für Enterprise
disabled.
Disabled.
Äh. Ne. Das brauchen wir gar nicht. Und haben
das
NoSubscription hinzugefügt.
Dann haben wir
die Shell aufgemacht.
Update.
Upgrade.
Yes.
Und jetzt haben wir den
Cluster gejoined als nächstes.
Genau. Okay.
So. Gehen wir da hin. Cluster.
War das hier?
Join Cluster.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Join.
Error. Hä?
Wie? Das Ding heißt nochmal
PVE? Ich hab das doch gar nicht
PVE genannt. Ich hab das doch PVE3
oder so genannt. Warum heißt
uns das Ding jetzt nochmal PVE?
Ich hab das doch bei
der Installation ganz anders genannt.
Hä?
Okay. Dann müssen wir wieder den gleichen Mist
machen vom letzten Mal.
Oh ne. Okay.
Da heißt er halt
Minus 2 heißt er jetzt.
Okay. Perfekt.
Save.
Und
Shell.
Okay. Ich hab die
Ich hab genau den gleichen Mist gemacht wie gestern.
Also.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
VI, ETC, Hostname.
PVE2.
Okay. Reboot. Zack.
So. Jetzt sollte er mit dem richtigen Hostname
hochkommen. Und dann müsste man ihn eigentlich
auch joinen können.
Nenn es PVE. Äh. Nenn es PVP.
Wir können es auch PVZ nennen.
Auf so ein paar runden Plants vs. Zombies
hätte ich wieder Bock.
So. PVE2.
Okay. Jetzt joinen wir den.
Auf E.
Cluster.
Ne. Hier. Hä?
Warum macht man das eigentlich hier?
Join. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Yep.
Hat funktioniert.
Ja.
So. Jetzt sollte man
eigentlich im Cluster gleich alles sehen.
Was will denn das von mir gerade?
Ich glaube das ist. Ich glaube wir sind
einfach zu schnell.
Ich glaube wir waren zu schnell.
Ja.
Genau. So. Und jetzt haben wir 3 Nodes
im Cluster.
Und nun. Laut
Chat soll das mit dem.
Ach ne. Wir brauchen noch ein Ceph. Oder?
Wir haben ja noch kein Ceph hier drauf.
Äh. Kekl kann ich übrigens mal
wieder löschen. Das war doch mein.
Das löschen wir mal.
Wie löscht man Storage? Das ist jetzt
die Frage. Kekl ist das
ZF. Ne. Moment. Kekl ist
das Ceph.
Pogu Pool können wir wieder löschen.
Remove.
Yes.
Ach jetzt ist alles
weg.
Okay. Wir machen nochmal beim dritten Node
machen wir auch nochmal eine zweite Disk rein.
Und geben dem auch nochmal 50G Speicherplatz.
Und legen den Ceph.
Oder machen jetzt in den
Cluster noch das Volume rein.
Mal gucken ob ich das noch kann.
Wenn ich wieder vergessen hab wie das funktioniert.
So.
Jetzt müssen wir einmal rebooten.
Den da.
Aber nur den da.
Yes.
So. Also.
Folgendes will ich heute ausprobieren.
Also erstmal gucken ob das mit dem automatischen Migrieren
funktioniert. Und was mich auch noch
interessiert ist ob man mit Terraform
Proxmox VMs aufbauen kann.
Terraform
ist so ein VM und
Container und Cloud Provisioning Tool.
Was
ziemlich verbreitet ist. Also ich glaube es gibt
kein Tool was so weit verbreitet ist wie Terraform
in der Richtung.
Es gibt ein paar Alternativen. Es gibt noch sowas
wie Pulumi zum Beispiel. Aber im Prinzip
kann man eigentlich sagen
zum größten Teil ist Terraform
das mit Abstand verbreitetste.
Sind das jetzt drei verschiedene
Maschinen auf der gleichen VM? Nö.
Auf dem gleichen Host. Ja.
Aber nicht auf der gleichen VM.
So. Ist es wieder da?
Ja. Wir sind wieder da.
Er sollte es eigentlich auch gecheckt haben dass der dritte
Node wieder da ist. Ja. Dritter Node ist da.
So. Wenn wir jetzt hier mal bei Storage
gucken. Disks.
Unused. Okay.
Zef. Wie ging das? Mal gucken ob
ich das noch aus dem Kopf hinbekomme. Man geht auf
Zef und sagt jetzt erstmal install Zef
vom
No Subscription. Okay.
Ja das hier ist finde ich auch
nicht schön gemacht. Ich meine
normal als Linux Benutzer
für mich ist das jetzt nicht wild. Dass ich
hier ein Text Interface kriege was nach
App Install aussieht. Aber eine schöne
Experience ist das nicht. Das sollte einfach unter der
Haube funktionieren und gut ist.
Was mit Terraform geht. Aber du brauchst vorher
Templates. Hab eine Repo wo ich mit
äh. Kann ich hier einfach sagen
ich stelle VM
und benutze dafür dieses ISO oder sowas.
Das muss ich mir gleich mal angucken.
So. Next.
Okay.
Kann man nichts anklicken. Next.
Success. Sollte das
Warning jetzt nicht eigentlich weg gehen.
Nee.
Sollte es nicht. Weil
wir müssen noch ein OSD erstellen.
OSD ist das eigentliche
Ding was dann aus der
Disk ein Zef Member
macht. Ja. Ich hab keine Ahnung
was ich hier mache. Und hat
das jetzt funktioniert? Ja.
Nice. Okay.
Wir haben ein Zef Storage mit 3
Zef Memory Membern. Das heißt
das sollte jetzt auch aufhören rum zu meckern.
Ja.
No Warning Errors.
Active. Wunderbar.
Okay. Wir haben ein Zef Storage.
Und jetzt ist die Preisfrage
Funktioniert jetzt das automatische
Failover oder nicht?
Chatgy. Was meint ihr?
Wenn ich jetzt einfach diesen Node
ausschalte.
Funktioniert dann das automatische Takeover oder
nicht? Also.
Das Ziel ist. Dieser Server crashed.
Ach ja.
Bestimmt. Wir müssen noch irgendwelche Gruppen hinzufügen.
Stimmt. Das
hab ich gestern. Das hab ich gestern schon
gefunden irgendwie. HA
Groups. Create.
Genau. Hier.
Cute Chat Group.
Create.
Und jetzt
sagen HA. So weil für die VM hab ich das
schon eingerichtet. Da muss man glaube ich
jetzt noch eine Group hinzufügen.
Die VM hab ich schon eingerichtet, dass er automatisch
das Takeover machen soll.
Jetzt sollte das gehen oder?
Was meint ihr?
Auch mal an die Leute die Proxmox ein bisschen
Ahnung von haben. Also von der
Idee her sollte ich jetzt diesen Node ausschalten
können. Und
die VM sollte migriert
werden. Wir testen das
einmal noch live. Wir sagen
Migrate zu PVE2.
Warten wir mal ab bis es rübergeschoben ist.
Ja.
Kunst.
VM ist rübergeschoben.
Okay. Migrate.
Wieder zurück zu PVE1.
Und jetzt werde ich PVE1
einfach mal hart ausschalten.
Und jetzt gucken wir mal was passiert.
Netzwerk ziehen reicht auch.
Das stimmt. Du hast recht. Wir müssen den gar nicht hart ausschalten.
Wir können auch einfach
Disconnect vom Netzwerkadapter machen.
Bam. Moin.
ThePlayer97 ist am Start.
So. Jetzt
ich mach nix. Mal gucken was passiert.
Wenn das funktioniert
dann muss ich Proxmox echt mal loben.
Dann haben sie es super easy
und naheliegend
gemacht für auch Kacknoobs.
Aber wirklich passieren
tut nix oder?
PVE? HA? LM?
Was?
Sollte der das jetzt nicht starten?
Hat er das hier nicht schon
gemacht gerade? Hat er das nicht gerade sogar
versucht schon?
Ne. Das waren auch die alten oder?
Was?
Hä?
Der CPU ist
bin disabled?
Der rebootet sich jetzt einfach. Der Kacknoob.
Alter.
Der soll sich nicht rebooten. Aber gut.
Das ist egal ob der sich rebootet. Das ist eh egal.
Failed. Warum geht das
nicht? Warum migratet
er das nicht?
Haben nicht richtig aufgepasst. Aber auf welchem Storage liegen
Daten? Auf einem Shared
Storage. Warum migratet
er jetzt nix? Ich dachte eigentlich das sollte
jetzt funktionieren.
Der hatte die Daten überall anders.
Der konnte jetzt
feststellen.
Vm ist weg.
Nur ein PVE hat kein Netzwerk.
Genau.
Die Oberfläche hat mich aktualisiert.
Alter.
Hahaha.
Oder hat er das jetzt erst wirklich
gemacht?
Es kann auch sein dass er das jetzt erst gemacht hat.
Das ist auch möglich.
Das kann auch sein.
Ne guck mal. Der ist immer noch
am laufen hier.
Ja.
Error start. Was?
Error failed start. Hä?
Was?
Konsole. Hallo?
Konsole.
Alter. Firefox. Mensch.
Geh mal nicht auf den Sack.
Firefox macht komische Dinge.
Der konnte nicht starten.
Oder?
Ne. Guck mal.
Da kann die Vm nicht starten.
Warum nicht?
Die Vm ist dead.
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Oder doch?
Uptime 1.19
Uptime
Zählen wir gleich?
Ne.
Die ist nicht richtig.
1A.
Angeblich ist die an.
Okay. Ping.
Ne.
Wobei ich nicht weiß ob die gleiche IP gekriegt hat.
Das hat nicht funktioniert.
Wir machen jetzt mal
Stop.
Keine Ahnung.
Stop sollte doch
wenigstens funktionieren oder?
Ne.
Anhand von meiner CPU sollte das nicht liegen.
Müsste ja komplett
abstrahiert sein.
So wirklich
funktioniert das nicht oder?
Doch jetzt ist er aus.
Okay.
Konsole. Start now.
Ja. Start now.
He does know he lacks
critical information.
Okay. Warum genau lässt sich das jetzt nicht starten?
Hä?
Ist das mega kaputt?
Oder ist das
Webinterface was rumspacken?
Die VM geht an sich.
Konsole geht auch nicht.
Was ist denn da kaputt?
Konsole geht nicht.
Was hat das Ding für eine IP?
Sieht man das hier irgendwie?
IP sieht man nur mit
Guest Agent.
Schau mal ob das ZEV noch läuft.
Ja.
Das
funktioniert.
Der Node ist weg. Das mag er nicht.
Aber das ist in Ordnung.
An sich tut das ZEV noch.
Ja ich weiß nicht
welche IP das Ding hat.
Das müsste die 144 haben.
Hatte sie eben. Aber vielleicht hat sie eine andere
bekommen. Ich bekomme ja keine
Konsole. Ich kann ja nicht nachgucken.
Aber ich mach jetzt einfach mal ein Chrome auf.
Vielleicht ist es einfach noch verbuggt im Firefox.
Naja.
Ne.
Das ist a broken.
Gehen wir mal auf das andere
Webinterface.
Ok. Die 30 ist noch da.
Auf der 30 läuft
das Ding ja auch hier gerade.
Das lädt auch schon super lahm.
Da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht.
Da ist doch schon irgendwas.
Ne. Das ist dead.
Ok. Wir schieben es
einfach mal woanders hin.
Migrate.
Also an sich
ist ja das Ding läuft alles. Es ist alles gut.
So wirklich gut ist es aber nicht.
Migration aborted.
Ok. Warum?
Unable to connect to
QMP
Die 4M ist dead.
Keine Ahnung.
Tja.
Das hat wohl nicht so funktioniert
wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben.
Also das überzeugt mich
jetzt nicht, weil der Chat gerade fragt.
Aber ich muss sagen, ich habe es auch noch
in keiner offiziellen Anleitung gemacht,
sondern einfach ein bisschen rumgeklickt und probiert.
Wobei ich jetzt nicht großartig
sehen würde, wo man da was
noch groß einstellen kann.
Was hat er denn hier bei Failed?
Failed
Command.
Er mag das nicht.
Wir können das mal probieren.
Ich kann den anderen wieder einschalten.
Netzwerk. Connect.
Aber das wäre ja
unsinnig, wenn das nur da drauf geht.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir die 4M überhaupt wieder
dazu bewegen können.
System CTL.
Also das wäre Failed, wenn ich da von Hand
ran müsste mit System CTL.
Guck mal, der Node ist wieder da.
Migrate.
Wieder zurück auf den 1er.
Ach, das geht jetzt,
oder wie?
Ja, aber das darf doch nicht sein.
Das ist doch gerade der Sinn des Ganzen, dass wenn es im Arsch ist,
dass ich es umziehen kann.
Da ist irgendwas falsch geworden.
Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht was.
Da ist er. Da sind wir wieder.
Ist er wieder am Start?
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, was passiert denn,
wenn ich den jetzt noch mal
verschiebe. Jetzt ging ja alles.
Okay, lass uns mal
einen Ping machen.
Okay, pingt auch alles wieder noch.
Gut. Schiebe den mal wieder auf den anderen.
Ist Zeff jetzt
glücklich? Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Aber Zeff muss auch mit 2 Nodes
weiter funktionieren. Das ist ja gerade der Sinn davon.
Das darf ja durchaus
in einem degraded state laufen.
Das funktioniert jetzt. Jetzt ist kein Problem mehr.
Jetzt ist alles gut.
Jetzt ist alles gut,
wenn der Node wieder da ist.
Zack, funzt.
Ja, aber das kann es doch jetzt nicht wirklich sein, oder?
Okay, probieren wir das
noch mal aus.
Wir testen es jetzt noch mal.
Ich gehe jetzt auf den 31er.
Und dann schalten wir den 30er aus.
Das ist der erste Node. Mal gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Keine Ahnung, vielleicht war es ja...
Ja, ja. Vielleicht war es ja
irgendeine einmalige Geschichte, dass es beim ersten Mal
buggt. Was weiß ich.
So, wir schalten
jetzt den ersten Node aus.
Was heißt wir schalten aus?
Wir machen das Netzwerk weg.
Ja, 30.
Nee, komm.
Es macht ja im Prinzip keinen Unterschied.
Wir sind einfach mal
ganz gemein und sagen hier
Bam.
Boom.
Big Shuck.
Node ist weg.
Gucken, wie lange er braucht, bis das...
Okay, VM ist weg.
Das lasse ich mir gefallen, dass der ein bisschen braucht, bis er das checkt.
Kann das sein, dass
der ZEV-Node noch nicht fertig war?
Ich meine, möglich.
Aber...
Ich meine, der muss 4 GB
sinken lokal auf eine SSD.
Das sollte er schon hinkriegen.
Nein, die VMs sind auch
auf dem ZEV.
Man hat ja auch gesehen, dass es migrieren prinzipiell geht,
aber die VM ging dann nicht.
So.
Noch ist die VM hier.
Hast du den
neuen PVE mit ins Quorum aufgenommen?
Was heißt das? Du meinst in die
HA-Group?
Oder was ist das bei dir?
Du meinst das hier, oder?
Da sind alle 3 drinnen.
Jetzt müssen wir warten.
Ich glaube, das dauert 2 Minuten oder so,
bis der anfängt, den Kram zu migrieren.
Das dauert
wohl ein bisschen, bis der anfängt.
Eben hat es ja auch 2 Minuten gedauert.
Guck, hier unten passiert noch nichts.
Da müssen wir kurz warten,
bis der jetzt anfängt,
zu migraten.
Der hat es noch nicht mitgekriegt.
No root to host.
No shitping.
HA-Group und für die Replikation freigeben.
Was?
Bei Replication
habe ich nichts drin stehen. Ich dachte, das brauche ich
nicht mehr, wenn ich Ceph anhabe.
Weil Ceph ja schon shared ist,
ohne irgendwas zu replizieren.
Ey, das brauche ich doch nicht, oder?
Wo ist der Sinn davon,
die Sachen nochmal zu replizieren,
wenn ich sie schon auf dem shared disk
habe?
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Webinterface?
Switcht das automatisch? Leider nicht.
Und es gibt auch keinen Service mit
Cluster-IP.
Was man machen könnte ist,
wenn man es hinbekommt,
eine VM
hochverfügbar zu machen,
dass man auf die VM
einen Proxy packt,
der auf das Webinterface
balancet. Das würde funktionieren.
Leider hat es keinen Cluster-Service
für die IP. Das wäre extrem cool.
Macht es jetzt noch irgendwas?
Guck mal, der hat gerade verschoben.
Jetzt verschiebt er die VM.
Aber es funktioniert
wieder nicht.
Es dauert schon viel zu lang.
Es geht wieder nicht.
Failed to start.
Nice.
G Eats.
Start failed command.
Migration.
Fragen wir mal Google, was die dazu sagen.
Task error.
Okay.
Genau das haben wir auch.
Seems like you hit a timeout.
Ja, ach.
Iso eingebunden? Nee.
Also, auf
diesem Note noch, aber
aber nicht in der VM.
Komisch.
Please do the following.
Don't suspend the VM.
Moment, will ich doch auch gar nicht.
Dann weiß ich nicht,
woran das liegt, dass das mit dem
Migrieren nicht
funktioniert.
Genau, das manuelle Verschieben geht ja.
Guck mal die komplette
Meldung an. Okay.
Ich kopiere das mal rein,
dass man es sich sonderlich angucken kann.
So, das ist die komplette Fehlermeldung.
Failed start, KVM, ID, Name,
Debug, HR, Dings.
Bloop. Bloop.
Ja, das ist das KVM-Kommando zum Starten.
Das dürfte
jetzt nicht allzu viel aussagen.
Alter, sag mal,
wie viel kommt denn da noch?
Okay, das ist es wieder.
Timeout.
Ja, da kann ich vor allem nicht starten.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen.
Man weiß halt nicht genau, welche.
Was komisch ist, weil die normale Migration
funktioniert ja auch.
Die Platte liegt auf dem ZEV, ja.
Mal gucken, was
passiert, wenn ich
den Node wieder hochfahre.
Ich mein,
ich kann das mal ausprobieren,
ob ich tatsächlich noch irgendwie
Replizierung einschalten muss.
Ich brauche die Replizierung eben nicht mehr,
wenn das alles auf dem ZEV liegt.
Zumindest wäre dann die Fehlermeldung ziemlich hängen geblieben.
Okay, der Node ist wieder da.
Du musst höchstens die
KVM für High Availability freischalten.
Haben wir ja gemacht, sonst hätte ich sicher gar nicht
versucht, automatisch zu migraten.
Welcher ist der ZEV-Storage? Das hier ist der
ZEV-Storage. Ja.
Ach, guck mal, da ist er wieder.
Der hat jetzt wieder zurück
migriert und da funktioniert
der Instant. Hä?
Gibt es noch eine Alternative
zu Proxmode? Ja, du kannst
ESX kostenlos verwenden.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was die
abgespeckte ESX-Version nicht kann.
Okay, das ist
WeirdChamp.
Ah, Xen und so Zeug kannst du auch
verwenden, ja.
Okay, aus irgendeinem Fall kann ich noch
Replizierung einschalten.
Ich mach das jetzt einfach mal.
Nee, Moment, Target...
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Dazu braucht man Replizierung, Help.
Das ist Storage Replication.
Ich brauch keine
Storage Replication,
weil ich jetzt auf dem ZEV fliegen hab.
Der Storage muss nicht gesunkt
sein, das ist ein Cluster
Storage, quasi. Der ist
gesunkt. Tja,
keine Ahnung, was der für Schmerzen hat.
Normale Migration geht
nicht. Proxmogs...
Fail migration
Das ist ein Bug, solange
die VM-ID 100 ist.
Meinst du wirklich?
Müsste da nicht bei allen im
ZEV Storage die VM-Disk, der ist doch
da, da, da.
Aber
letztendlich ist das egal.
Also, solange noch...
Also, der Storage
funktioniert ja, auch wenn
eine Node ausfällt. Sieht man ja auch hier
in dieser Übersicht.
Aber die VM-Disk
ist drauf. Auf dem
Cluster Storage. Also quasi auf dem hier.
Nee, nee, daran liegt das nicht.
Das wird nicht daran liegen.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Also, ich mein, vielleicht ist es wirklich so, dass
die VM-ID nicht 100 sein darf.
HA-Manager
Oh, jetzt wird's advanced.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was macht das
denn?
HA-Manager-Status.
Was auch immer das bedeutet,
aber wahrscheinlich, dass PvE
der Master ist.
Das sieht okay aus.
So.
Ich mein, viel mehr kann man hier ja auch nicht
machen. Wir haben
also Replication für
Storage brauchen wir nicht.
Storage ist da.
Shared.
Enabled, alles gut. ZEV ist auch
der Meinung, alles okay.
Wenn eine Node down geht, dann nicht, aber das ist ja auch okay.
HA hab ich.
Ich vermute mal, dass das so
geht, dass man die
Cluster-Nodes reinpackt,
wo das Zeug untereinander
migriert werden darf.
A resource can be restricted to run
only on it. Ja, das ist ja in Ordnung.
Das haben wir richtig gemacht.
Ich erstelle eine neue VM.
Ja, das mach ich. Vielleicht ist es wirklich ein Bug mit
einer VM-ID 100. Wir erstellen
jetzt einfach mal hier auf dem
Neuen. Wir erstellen mal auf dem Neuen was.
Läuft der
ARM? Ja, der würde ja schon sagen,
dass der Cluster nicht läuft.
Okay. Klonen die andere
ist wahrscheinlich schneller. Ja, du hast recht.
Klonen.
Target-Node
PVE2,
VM-ID 101, Name
0W
Resource Pool, Permanent
Storage, same as.
Läuft das Proxmox bei dir
zu Hause? Ja.
Oh, hab ich's auf PVE1
erstellt. Ich wollte es eigentlich auf PVE2 erstellen.
Da muss ich die gleich rüberschieben.
Also Chat, ihr müsst nicht auf Google
gucken und dann irgendwelche Sachen
in Chat pasten.
Ich erwarte von so einer
VM-Manager-Geschichte,
dass ich nicht auf der Kommandozeile
einzelne VMs in den
Cluster-Manager packen muss. Und das muss ich
wahrscheinlich auch nicht, weil man das hier überall
sieht, dass das wohl richtig
konfiguriert ist.
Zumindest sagt
er nicht offensichtlich was von Fehler.
Er erzählt, dass Ceph ordentlich funktioniert
und er erzählt auch, dass der Cluster ordentlich funktioniert.
Also das kann es
eventuell sein, aber es dürfte
es nicht sein. So, jetzt haben wir hier eine
VM. Gucken wir doch mal an,
ob das jetzt funktioniert. Vielleicht geht das jetzt ja mit der
101er alles.
0W wird gestartet.
Console.
Boah, geht mir Firefox auf den Keks.
Group.
Gut. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
IP-Add.
Hier haben wir die IP.
145.
Ja, hallo.
Nice. Funst. Alles gut.
Okay. Dann würde ich sagen,
probieren wir das Ganze noch mal.
Das ist der neue Node, der kaputt ist.
Der jetzt kaputt gehen darf.
Der hier. Der darf jetzt einfach mal
kurz verrecken.
Power.
Off. Bam.
Okay. So.
Schauen wir mal,
was passiert. Ob das wirklich ein Bug mit der
ID 101 ist.
Okay, er hat erkannt. Node ist
weg. Und jetzt dauert es
zwei Minuten. Irgendwo habe ich gesehen,
dass es zwei Minuten dauert,
bis er die Migration startet.
Das deckt sich ja auch
ungefähr mit dem, was wir vorhin gesehen haben.
Wahrscheinlich
braucht er zwei Minuten,
dass er sich sicher ist, okay, der Node kommt
nicht wieder.
Nee, hätten wir gar nicht gebraucht.
Das letzte Mal hat er
einfach, war einfach Zufall, dass ich in dem Moment
draufgeklickt habe. So, jetzt müssen wir
zwei Minuten warten, bis er
das mitkriegt. Ich kann noch mal
kurz hier in die Settings gucken.
Okay.
Replizierung muss man für
High Availability und
Live Migration nicht einschalten.
Das ist für Oldschool Sachen zum
Disk replizieren und sowas. Das brauchen wir auf jeden Fall
nicht.
Die VM ist in der HA-Gruppe, ja.
Guck.
Ach, shit, die Neue nicht.
Fuck, die Alte ist in der HA-Gruppe.
Die Neue nicht.
Okay, das wird jetzt nicht funktionieren.
Kann man das nachträglich machen?
Mal gucken, was jetzt passiert,
wenn ich das nachträglich hinzufüge.
Oh, das wird
er wahrscheinlich nicht richtig checken jetzt, oder?
Dead...
Das
verstehe ich aber auch nicht, warum ich das nicht
migraten kann, wenn das Ding down ist. Dafür habe ich
doch meinen Shared Storage.
Okay, wir warten jetzt noch eine Minute,
aber es kann sein, dass es nicht funktioniert, weil
ich den noch nicht in der Gruppe hatte.
Sehr, sehr komisch.
Habe da mal ein Off-Topic-Problem.
Ich möchte gerne ein Backup von einem
Plesk-Webserver runterladen,
das ca. 7 GB groß ist.
Leider bricht der Download immer exakt
bei 1 GB ab. Hat jemand eine Idee,
woran das liegen kann?
Schon komisch, reproduzierbar bei 1 GB.
Bestimmt irgendwelche
Settings.
Ja, klingt
naheliegend, kann durchaus sein.
Kenne ich mich nicht mit aus.
Vielleicht kannst du es
zumindest per FDP
vielleicht, ja?
Selbst nur nach 15
Webspaces hat
FDP.
Das hat wieder nicht funktioniert, Leute.
Ist wieder
das Gleiche.
Okay, jetzt bin ich echt mit meinem
Latein am Ende. Ich habe ernsthaft
keine Ahnung,
warum das nicht
funktioniert.
Gibt es da einen Guide dazu?
Proxmox?
Fail...
Failover
Migration?
Nah.
Der ist wieder auf PVE
gegangen.
Nee, wir hatten den doch
sogar schon mal ausgeschaltet, oder?
Hatten wir nicht den
sogar schon mal ausgeschaltet?
Doch, den hatten wir das letzte Mal.
Doch, das letzte Mal hatten wir PVE
ausgeschaltet.
Wir können das nochmal probieren.
Ich kann
immer den ersten ausschalten, aber
ich bin mir relativ sicher, das letzte Mal hatten wir den ersten
ausgeschaltet.
Naja, bla bla bla.
The first step is to enable HA for a resource.
This is done by adding the resource to the
HA resource configuration. You can do this by
GUI. Haben wir gemacht.
The HA stack
now tries to start the resource and keep the
Please note that you can't configure the request.
Ne. Okay, haben
wir gemacht.
Er hat ja auch bei Status alles
als okay angezeigt.
So, es ist alles wieder da.
Und jetzt wird er
wahrscheinlich gleich zurückmigraten
oder sowas. Guck, da. Bäm.
Frunz ist wieder da.
Ne, die
VM geht sobald
der andere
Cluster Member wieder da ist.
Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Guck mal, die VM
ist sogar noch auf dem ersten
und nicht wieder zurückmigriert
worden, aber jetzt geht sie?
Hä?
Da ist doch...
Da ist doch irgendwas...
Mach nochmal jetzt, wo sie...
Ja, ich hab das schon fünfmal
gemacht jetzt.
Da ist irgendwas...
Irgendwas ist da nicht richtig.
Ne, der Name ist nicht
doppelt. Da stimmt
irgendwas nicht.
Das ist schon sehr merkwürdig, dass sie jetzt
wieder direkt on kommt, sobald...
So, als hätte wirklich
irgendwas von der Config gefehlt oder so.
Und jetzt
konnte das migrieren. Sehr,
sehr merkwürdig.
Ähm, beim
Zev, ich hab einfach den Zev-Assistent durchgeklickt.
Nicht, dass ich
große Ahnung hätte, was er da macht.
Aber er meint, er ist healthy
und alles gut.
Ja, das kommt mir auch so vor, als hat er Probleme
mit der VM. Äh, mit
der Config.
Ich meine, gut, vielleicht hätten
wir das auch einfach nach irgendeinem Tutorial
machen sollen.
Also das ist anscheinend gerade der Host, so wie
er aussieht. Was auch immer
ich da gerade sehe.
Ja, weiß ich jetzt
nicht, woran das liegt. Keine Ahnung.
Fehlt mir auch die Proxmox
Erfahrung, da irgendwie jetzt dahinter zu steigen,
woran das liegen könnte.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen doof, weil der Rest
fand ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Das war auch easy
fürs Setup. Aber das
ist jetzt schon ein bisschen doof, dass das nicht funktioniert
mit der Migration.
Wir mussten die Nodes renamen,
bevor man sie in Cluster aufnimmt.
Sonst hättest du sie gar nicht in Cluster
aufnehmen können. Okay, dann weiß
ich nicht. Dann habe ich echt keine Ahnung mehr,
warum
es nicht funktioniert. Das ist schon
komisch, ne?
Ich schalte jetzt nochmal den Einser aus. Mal gucken,
was passiert.
Oh, bam. Einser
ist aus.
Guck, VM ist dead.
Aber das wird jetzt auch nicht funktionieren.
Macht ja auch keinen Sinn. Warum soll das jetzt auf einmal gehen?
Ich denke auch, dass es an mir
liegt, dass ich irgendwas falsch eingestellt habe.
Aber ich weiß halt nicht, was.
Wobei man das natürlich dann auch
ein bisschen auf das Setup schieben könnte.
Es steht überall
Running und Up und alles ist gut,
aber anscheinend ist noch nicht alles gut.
Hast du noch
ein Image eingebunden?
Nee.
Aber die Migration geht ja.
Die VM startet plus
nicht. Und die
Fehlermeldung erzählt irgendwas von Timeout.
Also da ist irgendwas grundsätzlich kaputt.
Und ich habe keine Ahnung, was.
Ist aber auch wurscht.
Fest
zu halten bleibt. Ganz so einfach
ist das mit Failover und Clustering
mit Proxmox dann doch nicht.
Zumindest nicht ohne mal geizig anzugucken.
Also ich gehe davon aus,
dass das normalerweise ganz gut funktioniert.
Welche Firewall? Hat das
standardmäßig eine Firewall? Also sollte da
eine Firewall Probleme machen, wäre das absoluter
Fail. Ich meine, das ist
der offizielle Cluster Wizard, den
man da durchklickt.
Nee, da kann auch keine Firewall Probleme machen.
Die Live-Migration geht
und der sagt
auch überall Healthy und Cluster Manager läuft
und sowas.
Nee, nee, das kann's nicht sein.
Ist der Host jeweils in Safety
als Monitor eingetragen?
Ja.
Achso, das kann ich mal anklicken.
Haben wir, glaube ich, eben schon geguckt.
Mal gucken hier, Monitor
am Start. Ah, Moment,
jetzt habe ich sogar den
Masternode ausgeschaltet.
Jetzt ist er komplett im Arsch.
Aber das müsste
er eigentlich auch hinbekommen.
Man sieht ja auch hier, dass er versucht
was zu schwenken und sowas.
Da ist er, ja. Da ist er, aber
er geht nicht. Das ist ja das Problem.
Die Migration funktioniert, aber die
VM startet nicht.
Datacenter Ceph? Okay, können wir gleich probieren.
Aber die Migration wird
wieder nicht funktionieren.
Woah, woah, was ist jetzt? Windows, please.
Was ist da los?
Wir warten jetzt erstmal bis der Node... guck mal, guck mal!
Leute, seht ihr das? Sobald der Node
wieder da ist, geht das Netzwerk
Instant, beziehungsweise die VM
Instant. Ist das
vielleicht irgendein Problem?
Von, gar nicht mal
von Proxmox, sondern
von meinem Netzwerk-Setup,
dass der irgendwie die
neuen, dass der keine neuen
Up-Requests schickt oder sowas
und deswegen die neue Mac
von der Netzwerkkarte nicht mitbekommt
oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Das ist ja nicht auszuschließen
bei so einem Setup. Ich mein,
das ist komplett virtualisiert, wie ich das betreibe.
Das kann ja schon mal sein, dass er da rumspackt.
So, was soll ich
machen? Datacenter Ceph?
Und jetzt? Das gibt es
nicht.
Du schreibst von Monitor
nicht
existent.
Das will eigentlich...
Ja, der hat jetzt gerade wieder rebooted hier, ne?
In PVR1, Ceph?
Ja, da ist
irgendwas eingetragen.
Okay, der ist stoppt.
Aber jetzt... Warum ist der stoppt?
Eben war er noch nicht stoppt.
Ach, der ist stoppt, weil das Ding gerade rebooted hat?
Warum muss ich da überhaupt
irgendwas von... Aktiv, jetzt ist er aktiv.
An den Noten...
Was? Create?
Einen Manager? Ne, was?
Ne, was soll ich machen? Warum?
Und vor allem, warum soll ich das machen?
Ja, das funktioniert.
Vor allem verschieben ist überhaupt kein Problem,
solange alle an sind. Das funktioniert.
Ich hab halt keine Ahnung von Ceph.
Was sagt uns das hier jetzt?
Ein Monitor
create? Mach ich.
Chat, wenn ihr das sagt.
Easy.
Und auch noch einen Manager?
Auch noch einen Manager?
Keine Ahnung, wofür der da ist.
Soll ich auch noch einen zweiten Manager anlegen?
Ich weiß wirklich nicht, was das macht.
Ja, wie?
Schadet nicht. Okay, bam.
Ich mach das jetzt einfach.
Vielleicht liegt es ja daran.
Und auf dem da...
Create?
Create.
So.
Der ist jetzt immer sowas von geklastert hier.
Der hört überhaupt nicht mehr auf.
Warum ist...
Ah, okay. Nice.
Ja, dann würde ich sagen...
Gib ihm.
Nochmal.
Gucken, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Bam.
Dead.
Wir müssen gleich feststellen, dass der Note weg ist.
Vielleicht liegt es ja wirklich daran.
Das wäre dann ein typischer Fall
von Peppkack, wie es schon jemand
im Chat geschrieben hat, wenn es daran liegt.
Chat, wer weiß, was Peppkack bedeutet?
Ich fang mal an
mit Problem exists
between...
Was ist kack?
Nein, nicht Peppkack.
Schreibt mal anders.
Keyboard.
Keyboard and share, richtig.
Gut, jetzt müssen wir wieder eineinhalb Minuten warten,
bis der das checkt.
Ja, Naruto House, ich weiß.
Was ich auch ein bisschen komisch finde, ist,
dass es keine
Möglichkeit gibt, das Webinterface
auf eine Cluster-IP zu packen.
Aber ich habe gestern
schon gesucht, da gab es nichts in der Richtung.
Is there a reason why there is no
Cluster-IP for accessing the Webinterface?
Das sind wie Leute,
die nicht checken, was der will, Alter.
Guck mal, das ist ja witzig.
Die schlagen exakt das Gleiche vor,
was ich mir auch gerade überlegt habe.
Du machst eine HAVM und darauf installierst du
einen Proxy. Ja, dass das funktioniert,
ist mir auch klar. Aber das ist
blöd, dass man das überhaupt machen muss.
Nee, das ist
doof. Also ich
hätte schon damit gerechnet, dass das...
Ah, guck mal hier.
Die...
Okay, okay. Nee, das dauert
schon zu lang. Das geht wieder nicht.
Das funktioniert wieder nicht.
Es ist wieder dead. Nee, guck, geht nicht.
Es wird wieder
dead sein.
Ich benutze eigentlich nie Chat-GPT.
Frag mal Chat-GPT zu dem Problem.
Da bin ich gespannt.
Nee, das dauert zu...
Timeout.
Es ist möglich...
Also...
Es ist möglich,
dass es an meinem Netzwerk-Setup liegt.
Ich will es jetzt nicht Proxmox in die
Schuhe schieben, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Vielleicht liegt es an meinem
Netzwerk-Setup. Kann sein.
Normalerweise müsste
der Node jetzt hier einen Up-Request raushauen
oder die VM hier nochmal neu, dass ich jetzt
die Mac... Wobei,
die Mac hat sich doch wahrscheinlich gar nicht geändert, oder?
Das ist doch immer die gleiche Hardware unten drunter.
Oder vielleicht doch.
Ja, dass sich die Mac
geändert hat und da müsste noch ein Up-Request
raushauen, dass das jetzt
eine neue IP hat.
Also das kann an meinem Netzwerk-Setup liegen.
Komisch ist es trotzdem,
dass es nicht geht.
Welche Distro hast du denn da und die
Arch-Linux?
Arch-Linux, by the way.
So wie die Profis das machen.
By the way, ich nutze Arch.
Ich sollte mal die
Gelegenheit nutzen, euch das näher
zu bringen, dass ihr auch
Arch-Linux nutzen solltet.
Weil wir sind uns ja alle einig,
dass Arch-Linux die
einzig wahre und beste Distribution
überhaupt ist.
Und es ist wichtig, dass wenn
ihr dann auch mal irgendwann Arch-Linux nutzt,
was ihr über kurz oder lang
dann auch machen werdet,
weil es eh das Beste ist,
dann müsst ihr das allen erzählen,
dass ihr Arch-Linux benutzt.
Das ist wichtig. Das ist ein bisschen so wie bei Veganern.
Könnte man sagen,
was Arch-Linux-User und
Veganer gemeinsam haben, man kriegt es
erzählt, ob man danach fragt oder nicht.
Das hat Einstein schon gesagt.
I use Arch, by the way.
Also,
um mal auf deine Frage zurückzukommen,
was das für eine Leiste oben ist.
Also, das ist I3, als Window-Manager.
Und die Statusleiste
nennt sich
Bumblebee-Status.
Das da.
Gibt's auch im GitHub-Projekt zu.
Es gibt aber
Tausende, das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen übertrieben, aber schon einige
solcher Status-Bar-
Projekte.
Und
ich weiß gar nicht mehr, warum ich die
genommen hab. Ich glaube,
weil man dort relativ einfach
selber Plugins für bauen konnte.
Ich hab mir zum Beispiel diesen
Timer hier gebaut, guck, wo man sich 5
Minuten in den Wecker stellen kann
für die Leiste.
Den hab ich selbst gebaut, weil
ich das für praktisch
erachtet hab. Kannst auch Pause
machen, weitermachen, resetten.
Und um auf
die nächste Frage, die jetzt zwangsläufig kommt,
einzugehen ist. Meine
Config findest du hier auf
GitHub. Und die
I3-Config ist hier und
dort Config, I3
Config und da ist auch
die
ganze Geschichte mit der
Leiste oben.
Wie lange hast du eigentlich vor zu
arbeiten? Du meinst jetzt bis
mein Alter?
Hab ich mir ehrlich gesagt
noch nicht so viel Gedanken zugemacht.
Sicherlich nicht bis 65, 67.
Garantiert
nicht.
Muss ich auch nicht. Dafür hab ich
mittlerweile genug Kohle, bzw. hab bis dann
ja noch ein bisschen mehr Kohle.
Und ich hab ein Haus,
wo ich, naja,
kostenlos wohnen kann man's nicht nennen. Häuser kosten
auch Geld.
Aber wo ich wohnen kann, keine Ahnung.
Solange ich Bock hab.
Wenn ich
keinen Bock mehr hab,
dann mach ich ein bisschen
YouTube und Twitch und gammel daheim rum.
Den ganzen Tag.
Und mach 24-7
Kreiselcrind als Rentner.
Wie heißt der
Song? Das ist aus irgendeiner Mario-Playlist.
Ja.
Das ist aus irgendeinem
Pokémon-Game ist das.
Oder wie die Amis sagen, Pokémon.
Pokémon.
Ich kann das nicht aussprechen.
Naja,
nein, ausgesorgt nicht.
Ausgesorgt kann man's nicht nennen. Also ich bin jetzt nicht
XQC, der 100 Millionen bekommen hat,
um auf Kick zu streamen.
Nein, ganz so schlimm ist das bei mir auch nicht.
Also ich könnte
jetzt nicht einfach sagen, ich arbeite nicht
mehr und
ich gebe
weiterhin ordentlich Geld aus und es reicht
für immer. Ne, das nicht.
Außerdem bin ich nicht vor kurzem erst 30
geworden.
Ich werd dieses Jahr 39.
Ich hab den
Note suspended.
Das ist aber auch egal,
weil ich die Note auch schon
Netzwerk getrennt habe
und shutdown habe.
Ich hoffe so in 5 Jahren.
Ja, du musst Big Stonks
mit deiner Firma machen und die dann verkaufen
für 20 Millionen. Und dann
easy money.
Easy.
Big Stonks.
Ja, bis 65
arbeite ich sicherlich nicht.
Das ist mir zu
blöd.
Hast du das so gemacht?
Ne, hab ich nicht.
Ja, ich hab
ETFs,
weil ich
keinen Plan hab,
was Investmentsachen angeht.
Aber ich mein Geld
nicht einfach auf der Bank rumgabbeln haben will.
Aber
ein Funding secure für Produktionsausbau.
Heute Nachmittag.
Ja, ist das wirklich so dein Plan?
Dass du in ein paar Jahren sagst,
ich lass mich ausbezahlen oder
wir verkaufen den Kram für Big
Stonks und dann easy?
Also bleibst du lang wie du Bock hast und
irgendwann sagst du, ich hau ab, gib money.
Ich verkauf euch meine Anteile.
Bei Scalable
hab ich die ETFs.
Oder so.
Hab ich.
Richtig.
Ja, das ist dann eh das Beste.
Dann kannst du auf Big
Boss machen, der zweimal
im Jahr in die Firma geht.
Und Rest
easy life.
Ja, das wär doch nice, wenn das klappt.
Ich denke, es muss sich schon
irgendwie lohnen, auch mal so irgendwie
ein Risiko einzugehen
und was zu gründen. Und ich mein, es kann
genauso in die Hose gehen. Ich find, es muss belohnt werden,
wenn's klappt.
Weil am Endeffekt, sonst würd's ja keiner machen.
Und es ist wichtig, dass es Leute gibt, die das
machen. Sonst tut sich
innovationstechnisch nix.
Wenn du Millionär bist, kannst du ja ein paar Subs giften.
Nice.
So.
Tja, Chat. Also die Geschichte
mit Take, wie er grad da ihr hatt.
Dankeschön für den Sub.
Tja, also mit Proxmox, ehrlich
gesagt, also ich glaube nicht, dass ich das hier noch mit
meinem Setup hinbekomme,
das ordentlich zu migraten.
Nee, funktioniert
nicht. Ich will aber trotzdem noch
mal was ausprobieren, bevor wir die
Proxmox-Geschichte sein lassen.
Noch mal ein paar Sachen ausprobieren.
Und zwar, wie ist das denn mittlerweile
die, nennen wir es mal,
Container-Experience?
Ja, haste.
Wie legt man denn
Container an? Wie ist das mittlerweile
gemacht?
Ja, create ct
pve
node
hostname
Ich muss Passwort
angeben für einen Container?
Okay, warum nicht?
Okay, next.
Template.
Wie jetzt? Gibt's da standardmäßig nicht irgendwie
Ubuntu, Debian, irgend etwas?
Ist da nicht irgendwas
vorgefertigtes?
Wo kriegt man denn die Templates überhaupt her?
Oh, jetzt nervt mich rum
vor allem Werder.
Auf den Local Storage klicken? Nee,
auf den Cluster Storage klicken, oder?
Nee, man muss wirklich auf den Local Storage klicken.
Ah, hier.
Nee.
Templates.
Ah, da noch.
Ach, hier kann ich jetzt eins auswählen, oder wie?
Äh, was haben wir denn da so?
So Debian oder sowas?
Wobei Debian Container ja
irgendwie relativ sinnlos ist.
Es sind halt
einfach LXC
Dinger. Das ist halt schon ein bisschen...
Kann man da auch einfach Docker Images
laden?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Nee, nee, das geht wahrscheinlich
nicht. Wollte grad sagen.
Kannst aber Docker in LXC installieren.
Ja, das ist das, was ich schon
gehört hab.
Wobei ich da sagen muss, das ist für meinen
Anwendungszweck, also ich verstehe
in dem Kontext das schon,
aber für meinen Anwendungszweck ist das nicht so geil,
weil
so ein einfaches
Interface
für ein paar Docker Images zum Beispiel,
wie das die Synology
NAS-Geräte haben,
ist schon nice. Da würd's jetzt hier
einfach sagen, Templates,
ähm, tja,
Container XY
und gut ist
Jubantu
Debian.
Debian Bookworm. Download.
Weil so brauchst du jetzt
einen Docker im Container
und dann
müsste ich da wieder dann irgendwie
so was wie Docker Compose drinnen machen, was auch doof ist.
Oder einen lokalen Kubernetes Cluster.
Was nicht geht, du kannst kein Kubernetes
in LXC installieren.
Dafür brauchst du
Volume Claims.
Verstehe ich irgendwie sogar.
Wahrscheinlich ist
in Docker zu sehr das Problem,
wie machst du beispielsweise
das mit Volume Claims
und sowas im Container gescheit.
Also die haben wahrscheinlich
da ihren Grund, warum das
nur in AVM geht.
Was natürlich mega der Seller
wär wahrscheinlich,
wenn die
Kubernetes API
hätten für Proxmox irgendwie.
Also sprich, dass man
sagen könnte,
man fügt quasi
seinen Proxmox Server hinzu
und der
handelt dann das Erstellen
der Nodes für den Cluster und das Skalieren
der Nodes und alles mögliche für ein.
Das wär natürlich extrem
Prog. Aber ich glaub sowas gibt's
nicht. So wir probieren
das mal schnell mit dem Container aus.
Create CT
Hostnames
Passwort 1 2 3 4 5 6
Highly secure
Template
Debian Standard
Disks
8G, ja das ist ok.
Cores
Network
Auto
Static
RCP
Bridge
Finish
Damit funktioniert das.
Es ist klar, aber cooler wär's, wenn das halt unter
der Haube für einen erledigt werden wird.
Dass man mit Terraform sowas machen kann, ist
klar. Wobei das auch
auch ein bisschen ne Krücke ist, im Vergleich
zu nem vollen Managed Cluster.
Da sagst du dann einfach nur
ok, so und so viele Ressourcen
und das Ding stellt fest, Mist,
meine bisherigen Nodes reichen nicht,
ich starte jetzt einfach ne neue VM
und füge den im Cluster hinzu.
Bin ich auch immer der Ansicht, wenn's
hier im Chat Fragen gibt, so
soll ich mir selbst ein Kubernetes Cluster installieren?
Sag ich immer nee, such dir irgendeinen Anbieter, der das
für dich macht. Gerade wenn's im Business Umfeld
ist, weil daheim ist das wieder was anderes.
Aber gerade wenn's
im Business Umfeld ist,
es muss ja nicht unbedingt
Google, Azure oder AWS
sein. Wenn's
günstiger sein soll, geht auch sowas wie DigitalOcean
oder bestimmt noch jede Menge
anderen Anbieter.
Leider kein Managed Kubernetes, das wär cool.
PrimeSub am Start.
Starbucks, Dankeschön. POC Subscriptions, ja.
So, haben wir jetzt
ein Debian laufen hier?
Start now, jawoll.
Start successfully.
PostChamp? Ok, das ist
jetzt halt ein Container, der sehr
VM-mäßig ist,
aber eigentlich doch
ein Container.
Ich mein, was man machen könnte,
ab install docker.io
Ach, eigentlich
find ich die Integration, wie sie's hier mit den
Containern gemacht haben, doch ganz praktisch.
Das ist
aber nur für den Fall der Fälle, wenn man
einen Container, sagen wir mal, als leicht
gewichtigen VM-Ersatz verwenden möchte.
Dann ist das eine coole
Integration. Für alles andere
brauchst du's
nicht und meistens
willst du Container eigentlich ja auch nicht so
verwenden,
sondern mit irgendeinem fertigen Service,
der drin läuft.
Du hast Docker auf den Proxmox
hosten sehen. Ja klar, kann man
machen. Das ist ja auch nur ein Debian, glaube ich.
Debian 12 ist das mittlerweile. Aber
trotzdem hast du dann
immer noch kein schönes Webinterface.
Wie beispielsweise,
ich find's halt sehr nice im Heimbereich, wie
beispielsweise, dass bei den
Synology Nassgeräten gemacht ist.
Da ist es halt super easy zu
sagen, hey, ich brauch jetzt mal irgendwie
einen Wiki.
Du startest einen Docker-Container mit einem Wiki und gut ist.
Hier müsstest du jetzt halt
einen Wiki auf dem
Container installieren.
Über apt und sonst was.
Oder du installierst
einen Docker und machst irgendwie einen Docker-Compose. Aber
Docker-Compose find ich mittlerweile echt eklig.
Also seit ich mich an Kubernetes und
Kubernetes-YAML und API gewöhnt hab, hab ich kein
Bock mehr auf Docker-Compose.
Proxmox-Helperscripts.
Okay, guck hier, ein Docker läuft da ohne Probleme drauf.
Aber das ist ja nicht das,
was man haben will.
Zumindest nicht im Heimbereich.
Zumindest ich nicht im Heimbereich.
Wenn jemand wirklich ein Virtualisierungskluster
daheim laufen lassen will,
ist denke ich mal Proxmox echt
nicht schlecht.
Ich weiß übrigens auch gar nicht,
was die Beschränkungen von ESX sind.
Von der kostenlosen ESX-E-Version.
Programmierst du deine
Web-UI selber für Docker?
So was will ich was Fertiges haben.
Unraid hat sowas zum Beispiel eingebaut.
Ich war jahrelang kein Unraid-Fan
und finde es auch immer noch ziemlich hakelig an manchen
Stellen. Aber insgesamt finde
ich es für den Heimbereich eine ziemlich gute
Kombi aus
relativ einfachem Management,
was Storage angeht,
was Shares angeht,
relativ einfaches VM-Management
und relativ easy Container-Management.
Ja, du kannst
eine ESX selber hosten, ich weiß.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was die Einschränkungen
sind mit ESX, mit der
kostenlosen Variante.
Das Proxmox Helper.
Proxmox Helper-Skripts.
5K-Sterne.
Pog.
These scripts enable you to build a Linux-Container
or Virtual Machine Interface.
Ach, das ist quasi ein
ein Wizard.
Ja.
Also es ist quasi ein Wizard
zum Erstellen von Containern.
Oder wie jetzt?
Hä? Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das ist quasi
immer die beste Idee,
Sachen aus dem Internet zu wegappen, prinzipiell
und dann direkt auszuführen.
Pog, absolut beste Idee.
Weil das in dem Fall okay ist, weil man
weiß ja wahrscheinlich, was man ausführen will.
Das ist quasi ein Install-Skript
für vorgefertigte Sachen.
Ja.
Okay, probieren wir mal aus.
Ich meine, kann ja nichts kaputt gehen.
Aber das muss man wahrscheinlich auf dem Host
ausführen, vermute ich mal.
Ne, nicht da drauf.
Da drauf.
Aber die Dinger sind doch da. Okay, probieren wir einfach aus.
Aber das ist trotzdem keine Lösung,
die mir gefällt.
This will create a new
OMV-LXC.
Jawohl, yes.
Use default settings. Nein.
To make a selection, use the spacebar.
Okay.
Unprivileged, okay.
Good password, null.
Jawohl.
Jawohl. Jawohl. Jawohl.
Jawohl. Jawohl.
Perfekt.
No.
Weiter, weiter.
Aber das legt mir das nicht irgendwie hochverfügbar an.
Yes, wunderbar.
No.
Yes.
Ja, aber Leute,
das hat man in zwei Sekunden doch auch
im Management-Interface zusammengeklickt.
Na, wobei, nicht wirklich. Man hat ja nicht das
Template von OMV da.
Aber dann bist du auch wieder drauf angewiesen,
dass dieser Typ der Install-Scripts dafür bereitstellt.
Ich weiß nicht.
Das ist alles eine Grücke,
für was was fehlt.
Ja, da sind mir Docker-Container auch lieber.
Beziehungsweise, wenn man halt
ein gescheites Management-Interface eingebaut hätte
für Docker-Container.
Man könnte natürlich immer noch mit so einem Crap wie
Portainer anfangen, aber Leute, ich hasse Portainer.
Ich würde das nie verwenden.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, dagegen habe ich
richtig Abneigung. Portainer gehört dazu.
Dann würde ich lieber einen
Single-Node-Kubernetes-Cluster daheim betreiben
und meine YAML-Files von Hand
erstellen, bevor ich mit Portainer anfange,
Alter.
Ah, nice. Sogar kaputt.
Sehr schön.
Und man weiß nicht, warum. Nice.
Sehr guter Eindruck.
Das sind aber wirklich alles Krücken.
Es ist cool, dass die Leute sich die Mühe machen,
etwas zu bauen. Schon irgendwo.
Aber das ist nichts, was ich auf Dauer benutzen würde.
Wie lösche ich die Kiste
jetzt eigentlich?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Wie lösche ich das Teil jetzt?
Aha.
Please enter ID.
103.
Destroy.
Merge. Bam.
Weg ist es.
Gibt es bei deiner Meinung eine gute Alternative zu Portainer?
Ja.
Naja.
Für
grafisches Docker-Management
wenn
du nichts verwendest, was schon
was mitbringt,
dann kann man das nehmen.
Aber man braucht
für Docker...
Man braucht ja kein grafisches Frontend für.
Wenn man
Docker-Container starten stoppen will, dann kann man
Compose verwenden oder die Dinger in irgendein
Script hauen und dann irgendwie vorne von Hand starten
oder von Hand anlegen.
Ansonsten
kann man eben das Eingebaute
benutzen in...
Wenn es Leute gibt, die Trunas verwenden, die haben
beispielsweise... Ne, wobei Trunas plötzlich,
Trunas hat Kubernetes mittlerweile dabei.
Onboard. Und macht
einen Helminstall.
Ja.
Also in Unraid haben die ein ganz gutes Docker-UI
eingebaut, standardmäßig.
In
TechnologyNAS Geräten haben sie ein ganz
brauchbares UI eingebaut.
Klick nochmal auf deine
VM und dann
Manager. Ist alles
eingefügt.
Achso!
Ach, dafür meinst du das?
Ja ne, dann nimm doch Docker Desktop.
Dafür ist es doch gemacht.
Ich dachte jetzt um irgendwas dauerhaft laufendes.
Du meinst auf dem Desktop? Ja, dann nimm doch Docker Desktop.
Das ist doch easy.
Bei der Gelegenheit können sie auch gleich ein bisschen
Kubernetes üben mit Rancher Desktop.
Dann nimm doch sowas hier. Das ist doch dann
easy. Da haben sie ne UI.
Die können
sich freuen.
Ich glaub Rancher
Desktop macht das nämlich auch sogar Docker
mittlerweile.
Ich hab das ehrlich gesagt noch nie
ausprobiert. Rancher
Desktop.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich kenn das
nicht. Ich hab das nicht
bisher nie ausprobiert.
Also es gibt
Docker Desktop.
Öh!
Ne, das mein ich nicht.
Ist das Windows auch nicht vielleicht?
Ach, das ist quasi so
ein
Mini-Kubernetes
Lokal. Ich hab das noch nie benutzt.
How Rancher Desktop
works.
Container D. Ne.
Das benutzt du unter der Haube schon.
Noch Docker. Ich installier das
jetzt einfach mal. Ich mach ein Snapshot vorher.
Und dann
guck ich mal, wie das ist. Ich hab das noch nie ausprobiert.
Was ist
die letzte Version?
1.9. Ja, gut.
NVM.
Ist das der Node-Version-Manager?
Yes.
Oh!
JavaScript-Based. Wir downloaden das
halbe Internet.
Da geht's schon los.
Gut, dass ich den Snapshot
vorher gemacht hab.
Guckt euch das Elend an.
Guckt euch
dieses Elend an.
Halbes Internet wird runtergeladen.
Der installiert C++?
Hab ich jetzt nix von gesehen.
Niemand mag C++.
C++ ist einfach nur
ein Hanes-Champ.
Ja, gute Idee, Leute.
Was macht es da eigentlich gerade?
Und was
ist Reifi?
Reifi?
GitHub.
Enable...
Moment, was?
Enable... Ah, von 2021.
Toll.
Enable ECMAScript in Node
Today.
Node kann doch schon seit Ewigkeiten
das normale JavaScript
importen.
Oder nicht? Oder doch?
Doch, oder?
Ah, guck mal.
Doch, doch, kam das schon lange.
What the fuck, Alter?
Was macht es da?
Erst noch mal Go.
Ja, genau.
30 Milliarden JavaScript.
Jetzt wird erst noch mal kurz Go kompiliert
from scratch. Let's go.
Noch mal NPM hinterher.
Gib ihm.
Okay, Leute, ich korrigiere mich.
Es ist nicht das ganze Internet,
es ist bloß 3 Viertel Internet, was der runterlädt.
Der ist noch nicht fertig.
Ja, PostChamp?
PostChamp?
Gab es da kein Minus?
What? Was kommt denn jetzt?
Golang-Elektron-Bindings
oder was?
Was nutzt ihr als Alternative zu Proxmox?
Nee, der Klassiker ist ja
ESX.
Und es ist eher umgedreht, dass Proxmox die Alternative
für ESX ist. Manche Leute
verwenden auch Shitrix,
wobei ich, glaube ich, Jahre kein Xen-Server
mehr installiert habe.
Nutanix CE?
Ist das nicht auch Xen?
Oder KVM?
Oder was ist das?
Podman soll ja sicherer sein als Docker.
Ja, da ist schon
was dran.
Docker hast halt das Problem,
wenn du den standardmäßig laufen lässt,
wie es ist, bist du halt
Root im Container, mehr oder weniger Root auf dem Host.
So, übertrieben gesagt.
Was nicht ganz
stimmt, aber in die Richtung geht.
Bei Podman kannst du ja auch die ganzen Sachen
laufen lassen, ohne dass
du einen Demon mit Rootrechten brauchst.
Oh, wir haben es.
1,5 Gigabyte ist das groß.
Okay.
Warum benutzt Max kein Podman?
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar Podman installiert.
Doch, wir haben auch schon
Podman benutzt. Wir haben Podman letztens
zum Bilden für irgendwelche Images benutzt.
Okay, jetzt hier Rancher.
Rancher Desktop.
Noch nie ausprobiert.
Das soll richtig cool sein für Leute,
die GUI-Zeug mögen
und kein Docker-CLI benutzen
wollen. Hier.
Oh, da ist es.
Enable Kubernetes.
Escort. Enable
Kubernetes.
Container-Engine. Docker
ist okay. ConfigPath. Automatic.
Da sind wir.
Rancher Desktop.
Diagnostics. Too failed.
Ja, dann fix
das halt mal.
Okay, er hat es
gefixt.
So, und jetzt?
Wie findest du das jetzt?
Downloading Kubernetes.
Gut, Leute.
Gut, dass ich
einen Snapshot gemacht habe. Ich habe jetzt sonst was
alles installiert, Alter.
Warum nicht Portainer?
Ich hasse Portainer.
Und auf dem Desktop
ist das hier doch ganz nice. Gerade, wenn man auch
in Kombination, dass man dann Kubernetes
üben kann.
Start in K3S.
Okay,
Images. Wie würde ich denn jetzt hier
Container starten?
Was?
What?
Ich weiß nicht genau, was der
von mir will, aber okay.
Okay, er ist fertig.
Äh, okay, und
File? Wie startet man denn hier jetzt
überhaupt was drin? General?
Wo hast du dein
File? Bei Kong
oder so hießen die. Kong-Key oder so.
Aber
kauft es bei irgendeinem ordentlichen Shop.
Ähm, wie starte ich
denn hier den falschen Container?
Leute,
ich checke schon mal.
Ich checke noch
nicht mal, wie man das überhaupt benutzt.
What the fuck?
Okay, das war ein Kubernetes-Dashboard.
Wie würde
man jetzt hier überhaupt Container starten?
Siehste? Keine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert.
One
selected. Und jetzt?
Muss ich jetzt irgendwas hinzufügen? Add Image?
Okay.
Hello World Docker.
Ich brauche nur den Namen?
Okay.
Wisst ihr, das ist ein weiterer Grund,
warum ich keine UIs verwende.
Das ist so super
umständlich und kompliziert immer alles.
Okay, und wie erstelle ich jetzt
da einen fucking Container draus?
Ach, Image-Management.
Aber warum habe ich dann hier dann
eine Docker-Engine?
Ey, keine Ahnung.
Wisst ihr, das ist der Grund,
warum ich einfach immer CLI für alles verwende.
Da weißt du,
was du machst.
Weg damit. Alles Schrott.
Braucht keiner.
Git nur über CLI.
Docker nur über CLI.
Kubernetes nur über CLI.
Ich bin übrigens auch von K9S
und sowas weg. Einfach raw
kubectl. Ich habe nur
zwei Plugins bei kubectl.
Link-Switch, Context-Switch. Fertig.
Beste.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich bin der Meinung,
wer Git nicht über CLI macht,
also nur mal
davon abgesehen, dass der sehr viel Potential
in der Handhabung verschenkt,
der wird es auch nie richtig
verstehen, was da eigentlich passiert.
Wenn du es bunt magst,
kannst du Asciiquarium nach
Lolcat pipen. Dann hast du es auch bunt.
Du brauchst
immer noch kein grafisches Git-Tool
oder sowas dafür.
Der einzige
Fall, wo ich
nicht
reine Git-CLI
mache, ist bei einem
größeren Diff.
Aber ansonsten
immer CLI.
CLI ist das Beste.
Okay, jetzt
Chatge,
überzeug mich mal. Was benutzt du
an GitHub Desktop,
was dir so einen Vorteil bringt,
was du jetzt nicht auch easy über
CLI machen kannst und zusätzlich
halt
nicht die ganzen CLI-Features
verwenden kannst?
Wieso, so viele große Diffs hast du
nicht?
Normalerweise hält sich das in Grenzen.
Also Diffs,
okay,
was ich meine, sind Diffs von einem
Merge-Konflikt, nicht einfach nur
Diffs. Normale
Diffs gucke ich mir auch ganz einfach mit
gitlog-1-p zum Beispiel an
im CLI. Das ist kein Ding.
Bei größeren Merge-Requests,
da gibt es ein paar ganz coole CLI-
GUI-Tools, die sind
okay.
Zum Mergen ist auch, wie gesagt,
das ist der einzige Fall, das meinte ich
mit, wenn ich mir größere Diffs angucken muss.
Aber wie gesagt,
nicht für zwei, drei Zeilen
und die meisten Merge-Requests
sind glücklicherweise jetzt keine
Sachbücher voll.
Also, die Merge-Requests-
Konflikte sind keine
Sachbücher voll.
Wie ist Potman einzuordnen? Was kann das alles?
Potman kann im Prinzip das, was Docker
auch kann. Ist nur von
Red Hat. Hat ein paar andere
Feinheiten, zum Beispiel,
dass du Container laufen lassen kannst, ohne
dass du Hut sein musst und sowas.
Oder, dass du einen Dämon-Prozess laufen
lassen musst, der Hut ist.
Aber im Prinzip kannst du sagen, Potman
ist Docker von Red Hat.
Gut. Ich mein, ich bin kein hauptsächlicher
Software-Entwickler, aber ich kann dir sagen, dass
alle Merge-Requests, oder nicht alle, aber die meisten
Merge-Requests, die ich kenne, sind deutlich kleiner
als 10-30
Files. Und von diesen 10-30
Files, es geht ja um Merge-Konflikte,
von 10-30 Files
konflikten wahrscheinlich auch nicht 10-30,
sondern
tja,
vielleicht 1, 2 und dann auch nur ein paar
Zeilen. Man könnte übrigens
auch sich das einfach
bei GitLab oder bei GitHub
oder bei Bitbucket oder so angucken,
wenn man kein Merge-Request-Tool verwenden will.
Aber die eigentliche Sache,
der eigentliche Merge
und irgendwelche Cherry-Picks oder
Leute, habt ihr schon mal ein Cherry-Pick über irgendein
komisches CLI-Tool gemacht, äh,
über irgendein komisches GUI-Tool gemacht?
Das muss doch ultra-abfuck sein, oder?
Das können die meisten GUI-Tools
wahrscheinlich gar nicht richtig.
Aber das ist auch egal, selbst wenn
die GUI-Tools das halbwegs gut hinbekommen.
Wenn du Git-Kommandozeile verwendest,
weißt du immer, was passiert und immer, was er macht.
Du wirst es auch besser verstehen
und du wirst auch, gerade Git ist nur
wirklich relativ kryptisch manchmal
mit Sachen, die passieren. Du wirst auch
verstehen besser, was irgendwelche
Fehlermeldungen bedeuten und eben was genau
passiert.
Weil Leute, die irgendwelche Plugins
verwenden oder irgendwelche
GUI-Tools verwenden, das sind auch die gleichen
Leute, die standardmäßig
zum Pushen sowas hier machen.
Das hat ja mehrere Probleme.
Das erste Problem ist gar nicht
mal Force.
Das erste Problem ist kein Remote angegeben
und kein Branch angegeben.
Das ist mittlerweile
gar nicht so schlimm.
Meistens hast du eh nur
ein Remote drin, nämlich das
von dem du geklont hast.
Aber kein Branch anzugeben
und je nach deinen
Default-Settings kann richtig
Probleme machen.
Und Force natürlich auch.
Aber ich kenn Leute, das ist den hier
Standard-Push-Kommando.
Und dann sind sie aus Versehen
auf dem falschen Branch und
pushen irgendwelche
Dinger, die sie vielleicht gar nicht pushen
wollen oder was auch immer.
Ja, gibt's.
Und das sind so Leute, die checken gar nicht, was sie machen,
weil sie zu viel GUI verwenden für Git.
Weißt du, was auch viel kann?
Die offizielle
Git-Kommando-Zeile.
Die kann alles sogar.
Ich wüsste beispielsweise gar nicht
gescheit in einem GUI,
wie ich dort ein Reset machen würde.
Na gut,
das ist relativ einfach wahrscheinlich.
Reset, neues Comet.
Ich geh da schon von aus, dass mit einem
GUI im täglichen Gebrauch
halbwegs klarkommt, aber man wird's halt letztendlich nie verstehen.
Ich mag das nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, Git
nur per CLI, Docker
nur per CLI, Kubernetes nur per CLI.
Dann verstehst du wenigstens auch, was du machst.
Ja, okay, das stimmt.
Das stimmt wohl.
Ich bin da vielleicht auch so ein bisschen,
wie sagen die Amis, biased?
Oder sowas.
Also ich hab da so ein bisschen,
was heißt das eigentlich auf Deutsch?
Voreingenommen, genau, das wollte ich sagen.
Ich bin da ein bisschen voreingenommen.
Ich verwende Git halt schon seit,
frag mich nicht, 2010
oder so, also schon irgendwie lange.
2011 vielleicht.
Also wirklich schon sehr lange.
Und ich hab halt damals mit CLI
angefangen und hab den Kram gelernt
und ich würde nie was anderes
als Git-CLI wollen.
Ich hab da schon so oft Dinger gefixt.
Relativ easy.
Weil ich genau wusste, was
welcher Befehl macht.
Das hätte ich mir alles nie über irgendein komisches GUI
vorstellen können.
Und es gibt ja super abgedrehte Sachen
auch noch, was du über Git machen kannst.
Weiß nicht, kennt ihr zum Beispiel,
kennt ihr das?
Chat-Git, wer kennt das?
Braucht man nicht oft, aber wenn ist ganz praktisch.
Okay, manche sind high IQ,
die kennen das.
Also was man damit
machen kann ist folgendes.
Stellt euch mal vor,
es kommt jemand von
der QS zu euch und sagt,
seit...
keine Ahnung...
Wir haben grad getestet und
es gibt irgendein
Bug und wir wissen nicht, wo der herkommt.
Aber beim letzten Test
vor zwei Tagen ging's noch.
Also, was macht man dann?
Man sucht sich ein Comment raus
von vor zwei Tagen,
macht ein Bisect
oder wie auch immer man das nennen mag drauf
und Git
versucht dann rauszufinden
also mit
Admin-Hilfe
welches Comment
die Software kaputt gemacht hat.
So, das funktioniert dann folgendermaßen.
Git
sucht sich zwischen dem aktuellen
Comment und dem Comment, den ihr markiert
habt als funktioniert,
sucht es sich random, oder wahrscheinlich
fängt es in der Mitte an, ich weiß nicht, wie es das macht
am Anfang, ja.
Da sucht sich ein
Comment in der Mitte raus
und dann sagt er, okay, ich setze
jetzt deinen Stand auf diesen Comment
dann probierst du aus
ob es geht.
Wenn der Bug noch da ist,
sagst du Bisect, nein, bei diesem Stand
ist der Bug noch da, dann nimmt
Git Bisect quasi wieder die Hälfte
von den Comments, fragt dich, ist der Bug noch da?
Dann sagst du, nein, der Bug ist nicht
mehr da, dann nimmst du wieder die Hälfte
zwischen dem, was du jetzt als funktionierend markiert hast
und dem letzten, was kaputt war
und so hast du innerhalb von
5, 6
höchstens
Iterationen den Bug
gefunden. Binary Search,
genau, ist ähnlich.
Oder wie
nennt man es korrekt? Divide and
Conquer. Das ist halt
extrem nice und praktisch.
Und es gibt
noch viel mehr solcher Dinger.
Ja, zum Beispiel,
ich erklär euch mal eine Sache,
Leute, die beispielsweise
immer nur Git-GUIs
verwendet haben.
Repo, ich mach mir hier keine Ahnung.
CD, TMP,
geben wir mal hier rein.
Hab ich noch irgendeinen Git-Clone hier drinnen?
Okay, was auch immer ich da geklont habe,
ich klone das Ganze jetzt nochmal.
So.
Und die Leute haben das dann geklont
und die denken
zum Beispiel,
dass Origin
irgendein Magic-Begriff ist in Git.
Was überhaupt nicht stimmt.
Origin ist
das Default-Remote,
weil er irgendwie
die Sache halt so nennen muss, von wo du geklont hast.
Das wissen die Leute nicht.
Und daran
merkst du auch immer, wenn Leute
da anfangen mit Git,
Push, äh,
Master, Slash,
Origin, wie auch immer,
die haben das System nicht kapiert.
Die wissen nicht, dass Origin
irgendein Git-Befehl ist, nicht irgendwas Magic-mäßiges ist,
sondern einfach nur das Default-Remote,
von dem du geklont hast.
Was du übrigens auch
umbenennen kannst. Du kannst auch einfach sagen,
Git-Remote, ich glaub,
MV ist es? Nee.
Rename.
Rename. Origin-Keckel.
So.
Ups. Was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Hä?
Git-Remote-V.
So als gibt es gar kein Origin mehr.
Als gibt es nur noch Keckel.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Leute zu blöd sind.
Ja, viele sind vielleicht
zu blöd, aber es geht
ja hier darum, nicht jetzt irgendwie
zu verstehen,
wie man eine Rakete baut.
Sondern es geht darum, als
Admin, Architekt, Software-
Entwickler,
DevOps-Typ,
was auch immer,
eines der essentiellsten
Tools, die es in der IT gibt,
zu beherrschen. Und ich glaube,
Versionsverwaltung mit Git kann man
da schon dabei zählen. Und da ist es
doch nicht so viel verlangt,
dass die Leute sich mal 2-3 Wochen
damit beschäftigen. Mehr musst du doch gar
nicht machen. Dann hast du den Kram kapiert
und kommst klar. Klar, du kommst
nicht in allen Details klar
und wahrscheinlich können die wenigsten
Leute jetzt im Chat mir erklären,
was der Unterschied zwischen einem normalen
Merge und einem Fast-Forward-Merge ist.
Oder Chat, wer wüsste es? Seid ehrlich.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem normalen
Merge und einem Fast-Forward-Merge?
Das wisst ihr wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das macht aber auch nichts,
weil euch das normalerweise gar nicht großartig
interessieren muss. Wie wär?
Rebase ist einfach, das heißt
1 zu 1 Rebase
und
Commit Squashen mach ich eh nicht, ich
resette und committe neu. Aber gut, da kann man sich ja
kann man ja machen, wie man will.
Also, ich kann euch,
wollt ihr wissen, was ein Fast-Forward-Merge ist?
Git Merge
minus minus noff gibt es
zum Beispiel. Der sorgt dafür, dass es
explizit keinen Fast-Forward-Merge
gibt. Falls ihr euch mal
gefragt habt, warum in eurer Git-History
immer drinne steht,
HerrEntwicklerXY
merged Master into
Master. Zwei Stunden später
HerrXY merged Master into
Master, merged Master into Master
oder merged Feature into Feature oder
was auch immer, dann liegt das daran,
weil der Typ eben
keine Fast-Forward-Merges
macht. Beziehungsweise
vorher die anderen Sachen nicht rebased
oder pullt. Also,
der Unterschied ist ganz einfach.
Wenn du einen Merge machst in Git,
dann entsteht normalerweise
ein Merge-Commit.
Das Merge-Commit hat zwei
Vorgänger-Commits. Nämlich
aus dem ursprünglichen Branch das
letzte Commit und aus dem Branch
in den du reinmerged das letzte Commit.
Und diese zwei Stände werden in einem
Merge-Commit zusammengeführt
zu einem neuen Stand.
So. Wenn du
jetzt allerdings
in einem der beiden Branches
gar nichts gemacht hast,
dann macht er einen Fast-Forward-Merge
und schiebt einfach quasi
den Pointer um.
Auf den neuen, auf den
Feature-Branch quasi.
Da gibt es kein
Merge-Commit. Das ist nicht
unnützes Wissen. Weil es kann durchaus
sein, dass es eine Policy gibt,
die sagt, wir machen keine Fast-Forward-Merges,
wir möchten immer sehen, wann, wie, wo gemerged wurde.
Oder umgedreht,
du möchtest deinen Feature-Branch
clean halten und nicht mit 50.000
Merged Feature-into-Feature
rumsauen,
wenn du da mit mehr als einem Entwickler
dran bist. Und dann machst
es halt ordentlich.
Und rebase das
vorher. Und machst deine
Commits obendrauf. Also es ist
nicht schlecht zu wissen, was passiert.
Und auf der Kommando-Zeile weißt du,
was passiert.
Wenn du
durchgestiegen bist,
dann weißt du, was du machen willst und was du dann machen musst,
um das Ergebnis zu erreichen, was du
haben willst. Und kannst die passenden Kommandos dafür
ausführen. Irgendwelche UIs
machen in solchen Fällen den
unsinnigsten Schwachsinn teilweise.
Ich hab schon Entwickler bei uns gesehen, die haben
Eclipse verwendet. Die haben laufend leere
Commits erstellt, weil es ihr hässliches
E-Git, nennt sich das Plugin für
Eclipse übrigens, weil ihr E-Git
der Meinung war, wir brauchen
zwischendurch leere Commits.
Also, ne.
Deswegen, CLI-Git
zu verstehen ist das Beste, was man machen kann.
Ja.
Deswegen hab ich mich auch freiwillig dazu bereit erklärt,
bei mir auf der Arbeit, demnächst mal
wahrscheinlich werden es
zwei Runden sein.
Eine Runde Git-Basics
zu machen,
für alle, die auf den Git-Mount-Everest wollen.
Und
dann noch ein bisschen Tipps und Tricks,
so, was ich so in den letzten 10 Jahre
mir
gemerkt hab.
Und Chat,
ihr könnt euch freuen, ihr kommt wahrscheinlich
auch in den
Genuss, diesen Vortrag zu
hören, weil
ich muss mir erst mal was überlegen,
was ich da erzähle.
Und damit das halbwegs brauchbar wird,
muss ich das mal ein bisschen üben.
Das heißt, ihr müsst hier als Versuchsobjekt agieren.
Das heißt, ich werd euch das hier
im Stream dann mal erzählen.
Du hast nicht Unrecht,
Git ist sicherlich nicht
das Benutzerfreundlichste, das ist richtig.
Das sieht man auch schon
daran, dass vieles ziemlich inkonsistent ist.
Manchmal ist es wirklich
Origin-Slash-Master,
manchmal ist es Leerzeichen-Master,
manchmal ist es dann
Doppelpunkt-Dings.
Und mein Lieblingsbeispiel
dafür, dass
die Git-Sachen relativ
kryptisch sind, ist immer die Manpage von
GitPush. Ich mein,
seriously, gibt es
irgendjemand auf der Welt, der checkt,
was einem diese Hilfe-Seite
sagen soll?
Okay Leute, also was macht GitPush?
Update Remote Refs along with
associated objects.
Update Remote Refs
using local refs while sending
objects necessary to complete the given
refs.
Obviously, alles klar. Also cringe, wer es nicht
verstanden hat. Und was ich auch immer
sehr spannend finde, ist,
you can make interesting things happen
to a repository every time you push
into it. Also, du hast
nicht Unrecht, Git ist an vielen Stellen
nicht unbedingt auf reine
Benutzerfreundlichkeit ausgelegt,
aber man muss sagen,
so kompliziert, wie das
gemacht wird, wenn man sich
ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, ist es auch nicht.
Es ist manchmal nicht ganz
konsistent, außer vielleicht für die,
für den Erfinder selbst.
Der wird wissen, warum es manchmal ein Doppelpunkt
ist, manchmal ein Leerzeichen, manchmal ein Slash.
Aber
es ist jetzt auch kein Hexenwerk.
Also man kommt da einfach dahinter
und dann weiß man wenigstens,
was passiert.
Im Gegensatz zu irgendwelchen Git-Guys.
Ne.
Es interessiert auf YouTube keinen, wenn ich ein Git-Tutorial
mache.
Außer will ich kein Tutorial machen, das einen Unterschied
hat, ob man einen Vortrag hält, eine Demo zeigt oder ein Video
Tutorial aufnimmt.
Deswegen lässt man ja auch die ganzen Kack-Noobs
nicht nach Master pushen oder nach
Main. Ja, ich weiß,
das ist eines meiner Lieblingssachen.
Guck mal, ich habe vor 5 Jahren,
das hören wir uns jetzt mal kurz an,
ich habe vor 5 Jahren schon exakt das
gleiche gesagt.
Und jetzt kommt der beste
Satz überhaupt.
Das ist 5 Jahre alt, Leute.
Recycle Story.
Also, die Git-Man-Pages
sind legendär verwirrend.
Ja, ich habe vor 5 Jahren schon genau
den gleichen Mist erzählt.
Ah ja, was ich jetzt sagen wollte.
Deswegen, das erste,
was du einstellen solltest, in deinem
Repo. Die meisten Leute
verwenden ja mittlerweile als Web-Interfaces
GitLab oder
GitHub oder Bitbucket oder so.
Da kann man ja das relativ einfach
konfigurieren.
Du verbietest erstmal allen Noobs nach Main
zu pushen.
Und dann machst du und noch
1-2 andere, die ein bisschen Plan haben von dem,
was sie machen, halt die
Git-Master.
Die Leute sollen ordentliche Merch-Requests machen.
Das habe ich schon über 10 Jahre gemacht auf meiner alten Arbeit.
Ich war hauptverantwortlich für unsere
Software-Repos und für unsere
ja, wie nennen wir es mal?
Nennen wir es mal Release-Management.
Wobei, wohlgemerkt
nicht für Software-Deployments
und solche Geschichten.
Und
es durfte auch keiner in Master merchen.
Es durfte genau
oder in Master-Branches merchen.
Oder Main, wie das
bei neueren Repos hieß.
Es durften genau 3 Leute machen.
Das ist das gleiche.
Ursprünglich hieß das Master.
Also im Prinzip sind
ja, das kann ich dir erklären.
Also ich mache jetzt erstmal das andere fertig.
Äh, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Genau, also im Prinzip durften bei uns
3 Leute in Master-Branches
oder Main-Branches merchen. Das war einmal ich.
Das war mein Vertreter
für diese ganzen Geschichten.
Und
noch ein anderer, der
sehr viel Automatisierung gemacht hat
und auch Durchblick hatte, was Git angeht.
So.
Unterschiede Main, Master
und der Trend ist ganz einfach, also
sowohl Main als auch Master
sind in Git nichts besonderes. Das sind ganz
normale Branchnamen.
Es ist einfach so, dass
standardmäßig das Ding
früher Master hieß
und heute Main.
Wenn du ein Git-Repo anlegst.
Also hier mkdir keckel
git init
Das ist standardmäßig sogar noch Master.
Ich habe vergessen, was ich erzählt habe. Genau.
Also, wenn du ein Git-Repo
neu erstellst, ist der Standard-Branch
einfach Master.
Daher kommt der Name.
Wenn du ein Repo klonst,
dann hast du zusätzlich noch
einen Remode drin, was sich Origin nennt.
Das ist das Repo, von dem du geklont hast.
So.
Und woher der Trend kommt,
das von Master in Main umzubenennen,
kommt daher,
weil es Leute gab, die der Meinung sind,
Master wäre
White Power und rassistisch
und hast du nicht gesehen.
Und das hat ein bisschen die Welle gemacht
vor ein paar Jahren und deswegen
sind manche Leute der Meinung, sie sind jetzt viel bessere
Menschen, wenn sie Main anstatt Master
verwenden.
Letztendlich würde ich so handhaben,
soll jeder machen,
wie er das für richtig hält.
Ich würde mich
nicht weigern, an Repos
mitzuarbeiten,
die Master als Hauptbranche haben
und ich würde auch nicht
irgendwie rumstänkern,
wenn es einer in Main umbenennt.
Das wäre mir ehrlich gesagt wurscht.
Genau, das kam so
zu gleichen Zeiten auf,
wo man auch gesagt hat, man sollte den Begriff
Blacklist nicht mehr verwenden,
sondern man soll jetzt Blocklist
und sowas sagen in der Richtung.
Ich glaube, die Leute haben schon,
wie kann man das nennen, so ehrenhafte
Intentionen dahinter.
Ich glaube, die denken wirklich, sie machen die Welt besser.
Ich persönlich denke, es macht überhaupt
keinen Unterschied.
Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass jeglicher Rassismus nicht mehr existent ist,
nur weil das Ding jetzt Main anstatt Master heißt,
aber okay. Ich denke, es soll jeder
für sich selbst überlegen, wie er das macht.
Aber daher kommt der Trend.
Das hat vor ein paar Jahren große Welle gemacht
und auf GitHub ist es jetzt so
und ich glaube auf GitLab und Bitbucket
mittlerweile auch, dass der
Standardname
mittlerweile Main ist,
wenn du es da anlegst. Aber es ist ja auch kein großes
Problem. Du kannst es ja auch einfach
umbenennen.
Touch,
irgendeine Datei, git add
m, git
commit, minus a,
minus m, init,
so jetzt kannst du sagen, git branch,
minus m, glaube ich, Master
nach Main.
Allerdings, und jetzt zeige ich euch mal, dass es vollkommen egal ist,
wie das Ganze heißt,
du kannst das Ding auch umbenennen in
kegw.
Also das sind einfach
nur Namen. Und prinzipiell muss man
ja auch sagen, in Git
gibt es ja streng genommen
eigentlich auch nur
Comet IDs.
Es gibt eigentlich nur Comet IDs.
Und sowohl Branches
als auch Tags,
als Comet IDs
selber auch, sind ja eigentlich
nur Zeiger auf Comet IDs.
Das kann ich euch
auch beweisen.
Das ist auch sowas, was Leute,
ich zeige euch jetzt mal ein Beispiel,
was Leute, die
Git nur über CLI verwenden,
auch wahrscheinlich nie verstehen werden.
Ich mache jetzt noch mal ein paar
Fake Comets.
Wir brauchen mal irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
echo 1, hängen wir an
an die Datei,
git commit minus a
minus m
keckel ist wurscht, wie das,
na doch, wir machen keckel
die Uhrzeit oder so.
Wir machen irgendeinen Counter.
Oh shit, Bash und
Counter, das wird jetzt was.
Wie war das nochmal, echo
1 plus 1,
nee, ah shit,
alter, Bash und
ah doch, doch, so funktioniert
das, ok. Oh, wie macht man
einen Counter in Bash nochmal?
Ok, warte mal,
i gleich 0,
oh shit, kann man
i plus plus machen?
Nee.
Oh, ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, wie man jetzt
einen gescheiten Counter in Bash macht.
Ich meine, was man bestimmt machen kann, ist
i gleich, aber das
geht bestimmt schöner.
Nee, das funktioniert nicht.
Ok.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Außen Kopf, wie man einen Counter ordentlich in Bash
macht.
Ich will mich da nicht so lange dran auffallen,
aber darum sollte es jetzt ja eigentlich gar nicht gehen.
Counter, Bash,
wie ging das nochmal?
Achso, er setzt i immer wieder auf 0,
du hast recht, da plötzlich, wahrscheinlich geht es doch,
es geht ja doch, was ich gemacht hab, easy.
Ok.
Komm mit.
I.
Dollar i.
Ok, es funktioniert, nice.
Sehr schön.
So, wir machen
mal ein paar Comments, ok?
Das hat doch funktioniert, was ich gemacht hab,
vielen Dank für den Sub.
Ok, wir haben jetzt
41 Comments.
So, also,
was ich jetzt machen kann, ist,
wir haben einen Branch, der sich kekw nennt,
ich mach davon jetzt mal einen zweiten Branch auf,
Git-Checkout-B,
den nennen wir mal ganz klassisch
Dev. So, jetzt hab ich zwei Branches,
die zeigen allerdings auf das gleiche
Comment. Noch, noch.
So,
jetzt mach ich nochmal einen Tag,
Git-Tag-A,
das ist Version 1.0.
Ja, so, machen wir noch einen Tag.
So, und jetzt hab ich drei Sachen,
die auf das gleiche Comment
zeigen, das ist das eigentliche, was Git interessiert,
die Comment-ID.
Ich hab den Branch Dev, was drauf zeigt,
ich hab den Branch DevDevs, was drauf zeigt,
ich hab den Branch kekw, was drauf zeigt,
und ich hab den Tag 1.0.0, was drauf zeigt.
Was Head bedeutet,
heißt, aktuell hab ich diesen
Branch ausgecheckt, also mein Head,
das, was ich gerade im Working Directory
habe, nennt sich das, also was man hier auf der
Platte liegen hat, nennt sich Working Directory in Git,
und das zeigt er auch
drauf. So, und was ich jetzt machen kann,
ich mach jetzt mal ein paar weitere
Comments nochmal oben drauf.
So, zack, zack, zack.
Jetzt haben wir noch mehr Comments.
Hier bin ich gerade mit meinem Dev Branch,
und hier unten hab ich meinen Tag.
So,
und jetzt kommt was, was wahrscheinlich
alle Leute, die ein GUI
benutzen,
nie verstehen werden.
Und zwar,
jetzt kommt der Punkt, wo
ich sage, okay,
mich würde ja mal echt interessieren,
wieso der
Stand war zu diesem
Comment. So, was die
meisten Leute wissen ist,
man kann ein Checkout auf Branches
machen. Wenn ich ein Checkout
auf Branches mach,
das ist ja irgendwie klar, dass das funktioniert.
Na, dann wechsle ich den Branch.
Was schon ein bisschen weniger Leute wissen ist,
dass ich Checkout auch auf Tags machen
kann, was aber auch noch irgendwie logisch
ist, weil
Tags
auch was sind zum
Auschecken. So,
jetzt haben wir den Tag ausgecheckt,
sieht aber schon ein bisschen anders aus, aber wir können mal
ins Loch gucken, wir sehen, das ist schon
das Richtige.
So, und man kann auch
Tags und man kann auch Comments
auschecken. Jaja, dass das über das GUI geht, glaube ich schon,
aber ich glaube keiner checkt, was da unter der
Haube passiert.
Ich weiß, die coolen Leute benutzen
die coolen Leute benutzen
ähm
nutzen Switch.
So, und was viele nicht
wissen ist, du kannst auch Comments auschecken.
Also wenn du jetzt wissen willst,
ey, was war denn zu diesem
Zeitpunkt, dann sagst du
git checkout
äh
auf ne Comment-ID. Das funktioniert auch.
Ich bezweifle auch gar nicht, dass man das in nem UI
machen kann, aber unter der Haube sind das
alles nur Zeiger auf eigentliche
Comment-IDs. Und es ist auch kein Unterschied,
weil jetzt kommt nämlich das Eigentliche,
was ich euch zeigen will.
Ihr könnt nen Tag auschecken
und mal angenommen, ihr wollt was ausprobieren.
Es ist kein Unterschied
zwischen den drei Dingern.
Es macht keinen Unterschied. Es ist egal,
ob ihr nen Tag auscheckt, es ist egal, ob ihr
nen Branch auscheckt und es ist egal, ob ihr direkt
nen Comment auscheckt. Also, ihr könnt
direkt nen Comment auschecken
oder nen Tag
und dann könnt ihr da drauf
zum Testen Sachen machen.
Guck mal.
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab jetzt nen Comment ausgecheckt
und ein neues Comment
obendrauf erzeugt. Das kann ich
jetzt, kann ich ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Ich muss nicht in nem Branch
sein, um da irgendwelche neuen Comments zu machen.
So.
Und mal angenommen, ich hab jetzt was gebaut, was funktioniert,
kann ich nachträglich
immer noch sagen, ich mach da draus
nen Branch.
Ja, das ist, das ist vorbei. Irgendwie bin ich jetzt grad
so ein bisschen in Git-Gedöns gekommen.
Und das werden, glaub ich, Leute in dem Zusammenhang,
werden Leute, die nen GUI verwenden, nie kapieren.
Die denken, glaub ich, ein Tag ist irgendwas Statisches.
Ja, der Tag an sich ist ein statischer
Zeiger auf nem Comment.
Aber ich kann ohne Probleme
Tags auschecken und mit dem
Stand weiterarbeiten.
Das ist ein Detached Tag,
genau. Ich bin jetzt nämlich wieder weg,
wenn ich raus bin.
Und ich kann Comments auschecken.
Das ist manchmal enorm praktisch,
wenn ich Comments auschecken kann. Wisst ihr
nämlich, wo das praktisch ist? Wenn ich weiß,
dass ich Comments auschecken kann und
ähm, dass ich auch in Comments
weiter, äh, in, in, nicht Comments,
dass ich Tags auschecken kann und in Tags
weiterarbeiten kann, macht
mal Hotfixes in Git.
Stellt euch mal vor,
ich hab jetzt Git-Check, ich hab
jetzt den Einser, den Einser ausgecheckt.
Hier, so.
Ich hab jetzt, bin jetzt
hier auf dem Stand von, äh, von dem
Version-Einser-Tag.
So, aber ich muss so nen Hotfix
machen. Also, Version 1 ist das,
was ich released habe, was aktuell
alle Kunden verwenden.
Aber, ich brauche jetzt
unbedingt nen Hotfix. Und der Hotfix
setzt sich zum Teil zusammen
aus, äh, diesem Comment hier.
Dann kann ich hier reingehen,
git describe,
guck ich mir an, welchen, welchen Stand ich hab.
Und dann kann ich sagen, git cherrypick
dieses
Comment obendrauf. Das wird jetzt nicht funktionieren,
weil die Zwischen-Comments fehlen.
Ähm,
und wenn ich das gemacht hab, also wir können
jetzt ja mal hier reingucken,
git, ähm, m,
der wird jetzt hier ein bisschen meckern
und sagt, äh, guck mal da, so viel
gleiches Zeug und hat sich alles parallel geändert, aber
ja, wunderbar, wir lösen jetzt den Konflikt.
Konflikt gelöst, git add
m.
Und jetzt sag ich, git cherrypick
äh, minus minus continue.
Und wenn
das hier fertig ist, sag ich noch mal,
git tag
1.0.1
und schon hab ich den Hotfix gemacht.
Guckt.
Das heißt, ich hab jetzt den Tag ausgecheckt,
hab da drauf was gefixt
und hab ne neue Version released, quasi
von einem alten Stand, der
bisher nur als Tag
noch existiert hat. Ähm, es muss kein
Branch sein, das muss, das muss
nix sein. Und da würde ich
sagen, wird schon langsam schwierig,
sowas über nen UI zu machen. Ich sag nicht, dass das
nicht funktioniert, aber da wird, da musst du schon
ein bisschen UI-Magic machen. Gehen tut das
bestimmt immer noch, bezweifel ich.
Es geht wahrscheinlich immer noch über nen UI.
Da wird's aber schon ein bisschen schwierig. Da musst du
schon genau wissen, wo du, wo du klickst,
dass du sowas auf die Reihe kriegst.
Und das ist eines der typischsten Art und Weise auch,
wie man Hotfixes macht. Also
zumindest aus meiner Sicht jemand Hotfixes
macht, der halbwegs gecheckt hat,
wie er git auf der Kommandozeile benutzt.
Und da kannst du dir jetzt auch sicher sein, du hast
nen absoluten clean State.
Du hast wirklich nur
den Stand von dem
Einser-Release,
plus das hier.
Und sonst nix.
Weißt du, solche Befehle nach
drei Wochen, ja, weiß ich noch.
Das ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich nur
goodCLI verwende. Außerdem
ist die beste Doku immer noch deine
Shell-History. Ach ja,
und jetzt zeig ich euch nochmal was,
was wahrscheinlich auch einige Leute
ähm
mit GUI
nicht so richtig auf die
Reihe kriegen oder nicht wissen. Wobei das wahrscheinlich
einfach im GUI sich anzugucken ist.
Aber du musst erstmal wissen, dass es das gibt.
Das sind ieds 2-3
Klicks im GUI. Will ich gar nicht
bezweifeln, kann ich mir vorstellen, ich würd mal sagen,
wahrscheinlich ein paar mehr als 2-3. Aber du musst halt
tatsächlich genau wissen, was du machst.
Und keine GUI-Fallstricke.
Und über keine GUI-Fallstricke fallen.
Und leere Commits erzeugen
und so'n Geschiss.
Was ich schon öfters gesehen hab.
Bei der Kommandozeile hast du halt den Vorteil,
du weißt, weil es ist das,
was die Git-Macher
erstellt haben. Du weißt genau, was
passiert. Bei meinem GUI bin ich mir
nicht so sicher, was das macht.
Ich weiß halt auch genau, was ich machen will. Ich will exakt
diesen Stand auschecken, ein
Commit oben drauf machen, vielleicht den Merch-Konflikt
lösen, das neu taggen und pushen und gut ist.
So, und jetzt zeig ich euch nochmal
ne Sache. Wir machen jetzt
wir machen jetzt nochmal nen Stand.
So, wir gehen jetzt mal wieder
in unseren Dev-Branch.
Findest du Git-GUIs? Was findest du schlechter oder
besser? Git-GUIs oder
C++? Naja, gut, die Frage stellt
sich nicht. Dann Git-GUIs. Es gibt eigentlich fast
nichts, was schlimmer ist als C++ in der
IT. Aber gut, das ist...
Ich find beides kacke, aber C++ ist nochmal
deutlich nerviger.
Chat, ich les mir das gleich durch, aber das will ich euch
nochmal zeigen. So, wir machen jetzt
nochmal nen Branch auf.
Keine Ahnung.
Dev2. Immer schöne Namen.
So, jetzt mach ich... Ich mach nochmal
zwei Comets. Also wir haben jetzt noch
Comet, Keckel 54,
53 und 52. So.
Git checkout dev. Ich geh jetzt
in den normalen Dev und jetzt sag ich Git-Branch-D
dev2.
So.
Chat-Gear. Dev ist weg.
Aber
mir fällt gerade auf,
ich hab da drin
was gemacht, was ich noch brauche.
Beziehungsweise ich nachgucken will.
Was macht ihr jetzt?
Was macht ihr jetzt? Ihr habt den
Branch schon gelöscht.
Manche sind bestimmt schlau, die wissen's von euch.
Ja! Alter.
Guck mal, wir haben ein paar richtige Git
Six-Heads am Start.
Neu-Klonen. Ne, Neu-Klonen ist nicht. Du hast das nur
lokal gemacht. Richtig. Du sagst
Git-Ref-Log. Da habt ihr nämlich eine
History, was übrigens
nur bei euch lokal gespeichert
wird, diese History.
Ihr habt eine Edit-History. Also solltet
ihr euren Git-Ordner löschen
oder Neu-Klonen ist das weg.
Also.
Du machst ein Ref-Log und ein Ref-Log ist
nicht der Log, nicht der Comet-Log
von eurem Repo,
sondern ein
Change-Log lokal bei euch,
was ihr gemacht habt.
Und ihr seht hier zum Beispiel, okay,
was hab ich gemacht? Ich bin hier
von dev nach
dev2, hab diese zwei Comets
gemacht und dann bin ich
zurück. Also was kann ich
jetzt machen? Ich schnapp mir die Comet-ID
und jetzt ergibt
das Ganze auch wieder den Sinn, was ich euch vorher erzählt
hab. Ich schnapp mir
die Comet-ID und wenn man jetzt weiß,
dass man ein Checkout machen kann, auch auf
diese Comet-ID,
dann kann ich mir den ganzen Kram angucken.
Sagen wir, Git-Log-1-P guck ich
mir das Diff an vom letzten Comet oder
Minus-3 oder so für die letzten drei Comets.
Ja.
Und ich weiß
mit CLI exakt, was passiert und exakt,
was ich mache. So
sieht's aus. Und das ist doch ganz
nice. Stashen
gibt's auch bei GUIs nicht immer.
Ja, ist auch so
ein Ding. Stash ist auch was sehr praktisches.
Und zwar,
stellt euch mal vor,
wir gehen jetzt mal, wir gehen jetzt mal wieder
in unseren, wir gehen jetzt mal in unseren Dev.
Wir machen mal ein realistisches Beispiel. So.
Wir sind in unserem Dev-Branch
und wir sind grad
am Editieren von so einem geilen neuen Feature.
Und unser neues Feature ist, dass hier
jetzt eine 2 steht, anstatt eine 1.
Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet, also das ist
das absolut nächste
große Ding, dass da jetzt eine 2 steht.
So, Git-Status,
wir sind mitten am entwickeln. So, und jetzt
kommt unser Chef rein. Unser Chef sagt, Max!
Produktionsfehler!
Wir brauchen unbedingt
einen Hotfix von der letzten Version.
Tja,
ähm,
eigentlich müsste ich jetzt sagen,
Git-Checkout
minus 1.0.1
und da sagt er, ah nee, das geht ja nicht,
weil ich hab ja noch uncommittete Changes
und die passen ja auch nicht zu dem anderen Kram.
Ähm,
was mach ich denn jetzt?
Gut, die einfachste Variante ist,
ich hab verstanden, dass du
ein geiler, äh, Drunken Myers, ich hab verstanden,
dass du ein geiler GUI-Checker bist. Du musst das jetzt
nicht bei jedem Ding schreiben, dass du das
auch irgendwie über dein GUI machen kannst.
Das geht jetzt allgemein drum.
Ähm, aber ich bleib trotzdem dabei,
einfacher und klarer, was passiert,
ist es nach wie vor im GUI und ich kann nicht verstehen,
äh, im CLI und ich kann nicht verstehen, wie man
GUI verwendet.
So, also jetzt musst du, normalerweise
müsstest du jetzt den Tag auschecken und einen neuen Tag machen.
Geht aber nicht. Jetzt hast du zwei Varianten.
Entweder
du committest das
unfertig, so nach dem
Motto, ja, äh,
ich brauch ein neues Commit, ja,
Chef kam gerade rein, hier
Zwischenstand oder so, ja.
Du committest das
und dann kannst du das wechseln
und dann kommst du das nächste Mal
in den Branch zurück und du könntest beispielsweise
das Ganze noch mit einem Reset
wieder rückgängig machen, dann bist du wieder auf dem alten Stand,
hast aber die Sache wieder in deinem Working Tree drinnen.
Was du allerdings auch machen kannst,
ist, ja, Merge Conflict
Resolven finde ich GUIs sind auch
ab einer gewissen Größe angebracht, ist aber auch wirklich
der einzige Fall. So, was du allerdings
machen kannst, ist Git Stash.
Git Stash, speicher das
in einem Zwischenstand,
du kannst dich auch auflisten lassen
und du siehst jetzt hier, guck mal da,
Working State is clean,
Git Checkout
auf den letzten Produktionstag,
ähm,
dann fixt du die Sache,
sagst okay, der Fix für Produktion ist
hier muss diese Zeile raus,
dann sagst du Commit, ja,
Best,
Best Fix Ever,
dann wird das Ganze getaggt als
1-0-2 und dann bist du fertig,
dann wirst du das Ganze jetzt pushen
und schon hättest du deinen Chef
glücklich gemacht, dann gehst du zurück
nach Dev, sagst
Git Stash Pop
und arbeitest weiter an der Stelle, wo du aufgehört hast.
Ja, das sind so Feinheiten,
die muss man nicht unbedingt können,
man kann auch anerweilig mit
Git glücklich werden, aber es ist schon
enorm praktisch.
Dann vergisst du am nächsten Morgen,
dass du einen Stash hattest, nee, das vergisst du nicht,
weil mein Prompt,
weil mein Prompt mir das anzeigt, dass ich noch einen Stash
habe, deswegen vergesse ich das nicht.
Tja, vielleicht,
vielleicht hatte ja der Mitte 40
Dev in dem Fall recht,
vielleicht auch nicht, ich meine, ich kenne den nicht,
aber ich denke, der Vorteil
sollte sich doch jedem erschließen,
allein schon für
den, also allein schon in dem Fall,
dass du
besser verstehst, was genau passiert
und wenn du weißt,
was du machen willst,
dass du die Tools verwendest,
die Hersteller sich
gedacht haben, dafür zu verwenden
und du dir sicher sein kannst, es passiert
sonst nichts anderes.
Ich meine, ich will keinen davon abhalten,
einen GUI zu verwenden, aber ich kann's
nicht verstehen, wie man lieber einen GUI verwenden kann.
Zumal alle GUIs
sich auch irgendwie anders bedienen.
Deine Kommandozeile, deine Git-Kommandozeile
sind sich immer gleich.
Wenn du jetzt die Visual Studio Code
Integration verwendest, funktioniert die anders
wie die Emacs-Integration, anders wie die Eclipse-Integration
und außerdem habe ich schon
oft genug den Fall
erlebt, ich weiß, nennt man ja
so schön neudeutsch, wie
wie nennt man das nochmal?
Anekdotische Evidenz oder sowas,
dass Leute mit ihren GUIs eben
nicht richtig umgehen können und leere Commits
und so einen Blödsinn erzeugen.
Und was das macht im Hintergrund, lernst du einfach nur
die Kommandozeile.
Und du bist auch
präziser und schneller mit der Kommandozeile,
kann mir keiner irgendwas erzählen.
Aber wenn du lieber GUIs verwendest,
benutzt lieber GUIs, kann jeder machen, was er will.
Also Merge-Request ist das
Einzige, wo ich mir gefallen lasse, dass
Wups, was ist das?
Merge-Request ist das Einzige, wo ich mir das gefallen lasse.
Für den Div.
Eventuell auch, wenn du
wirklich so abgedrehte Sachen machst,
ähm,
wie
verschiedene, also mehrere,
dass du nicht alles Commits, sondern
mehrere Commits nacheinander erzeugst,
mit exakt den Dateien drin
und dann nur Teile von den Dateien,
wenn man sowas macht,
dann könnte ich mir das vorstellen, dass das vielleicht auch beim GUI
ganz, ganz, ganz nice ist.
Git Blame ist auch nicer
in der UI.
Naja.
Okay, vielleicht.
Aber das geht auf der Kommandozeile
ganz gut, aber okay, das lasse ich mir noch irgendwie gefallen.
Okay, Leute, ich lasse, wenn ich
mir so recht überlege, ja, okay,
es gibt noch mehr Fälle,
als nur Merge-Requests.
Also irgendwelche Graphen sich angucken,
wie Sachen ineinander gemerged,
das mache ich zum Beispiel auch mit einer GUI,
wenn ich es denn mal mache, das stimmt.
Und,
ja, wenn ich mehrere Sachen einzeln,
einzeln von Dateien in unterschiedliche
Commits aufteilen würde, dann
vielleicht auch über einen GUI, aber das mache ich sehr selten.
Aber der Rest,
wüsste ich immer noch nicht, warum ich
einen GUI verwenden sollte.
Git GUIs in C++,
oh, das wäre, das wäre wirklich,
das wäre wirklich der Hammer.
Ne, ich meine, Leute, verwendet, was ihr wollt.
Wichtig ist, dass euer Workflow
funktioniert und wenn, wie hieß
er nochmal,
wenn der
Trunken Myers einen GUI verwenden will,
kann er einen GUI verwenden.
Ich verwende für meine tägliche Arbeit auf jeden Fall keinen GUI.
Oder nur für ganz bestimmte Anlässe.
Einen GUI.
Ich komme mit Git-Kommandozeilen einfach besser aus
und ich bleibe dabei,
zum Lernen, was passiert, ist Kommandozeile
einfach deutlich besser.
Und wenn man präzise weiß, was man machen will
und es ist vielleicht jetzt auch nicht so super naheliegend ist,
dann kann man sich bei der Kommandozeile
darauf verlassen, dass exakt das passiert, was ich will.
Keine leeren Commits entstehen
oder
auf irgendwelche falschen Sachen blöd
rebased wird oder irgendwelche komischen
Dinger,
Merged Master into Master 50 mal,
was auch immer, was ich alles schon gesehen habe.
Ich bin eindeutig
für CLI-Bedienung.
Ja.
Es gab, glaube ich, eine Sache, die ich
euch gerade noch zeigen wollte, aber das habe ich
vergessen jetzt.
Reflog getagged
haben wir.
Ah, ich weiß nicht mehr.
Nochmal kurz Questions checken.
Was das ist, weiß ich noch nicht.
Aus den Fingern saugen.
Rebase.
Na, das machen wir jetzt heute nicht mehr.
Ein Rebase ist allerdings
Nee, was
erzähl ich denn?
Warte mal.
Ja, jetzt weiß ich, was ich sagen wollte.
Ein Rebase gibt es ja eigentlich gar nicht.
Das ist auch so was. Das lernst du wahrscheinlich
nicht durch ein GUI benutzen.
Da musst du dich schon ein bisschen
mit Git und auch ein bisschen CLI auseinandersetzen.
Ein Rebase gibt es ja eigentlich
gar nicht.
Ein Rebase ist ein Reset
gefolgt von einer Schleife mit
Cherrypicks drin.
Also bei einem Rebase wird resettet auf den Stand
auf den du rebasen willst und danach
wird die Sachen, die du
mehr hattest, per Cherrypick obendrauf
applied.
Ja, Bisekt hatten wir schon.
Also ein Rebase im CLI
gibt es eigentlich gar nicht mal.
Ja, Leute, es ist gut verwendet.
Ihr müsst mich nicht versuchen zu überzeugen.
Ich benutze weiter Kommandozeile.
Wenn ihr GUIs verwenden wollt, könnt ihr das ruhig machen.
Aber ich denke,
so ein paar Sachen
waren hoffentlich trotzdem ganz einleuchtend.
Ja.
Unterm Strich könnt ihr verwenden, was ihr wollt.
Ich werde euch dafür auch nicht bannen.
Weil ihr Git-GUIs verwendet.
Wenn ihr C++ mögt vielleicht,
aber nicht, weil ihr Git-GUIs mögt.
So, das hatten wir schon alles.
Ja, mir auch nicht.
Aber das ging heiß her.
Wisst ihr, was meine Lieblings-Drama-
Open-Source-Diskussion aller Zeiten ist?
Der Weihnachtsmann-Hut
bei VLC.
Was passiert, wenn man Tags auf einem
Branch macht, dann den Branch
löscht? Nix, die bleiben da.
Weil die Tags nicht an Branches
gebunden sind, sondern auf
Comments zeigen.
Was, finde ich, man auch deutlich
besser lernt, wenn man sich das Ganze in Ruhe
anguckt und CLI benutzt.
Ja, sehe ich genauso.
Nur noch CLI.
Man sollte es pragmatisch machen.
Wenn es Anwendungsfälle gibt, wo eine UI
sinnvoll ist, dann kann man es verwenden.
Für Merge-Konflikte zum Beispiel.
Oder für längere Diffs
meinetwegen auch. Wenn man längere
Git-Playmen hat oder
irgendwie super komplizierte
Ads braucht für einen
Comment, wo man einzelne Zeilen markiert,
hinzufügt die nächsten Zeilen im anderen Comment.
Aber ansonsten
99% CLI.
Da weiß man wenigstens, was passiert.
Oder Graphen anzeigen lassen und so.
Lass ich mir gefallen, aber ansonsten 99%
CLI.
Magst du erklären, wie
man ein Rebase rückgängig
macht? Ja, das ist
relativ einfach. Du resettest auf den Stand,
bevor du den Rebase gemacht hast.
Geht Revlog auf,
falls du den Stand nicht mehr hast.
Geht Reset-Hard
auf die
ID vorher.
Ich zeig euch das, wenn wir
Git-Stream machen.
Das geht
übrigens auch.
Der bessere Weg ist
wahrscheinlich Revlog gucken, welche ID
hatte das Ding davor.
Und dann Reset-Hard drauf. Fertig.
Git-Rere
hab ich auch an, wie ihr seht.
Da sieht man daran, wenn ich
Git-Loggeschreib
dann sagt er hier, guck mal,
du meintest doch sicherlich Log.
Und das ist, glaube ich,
Git-Rere als Feature. Oder war
Rere die Geschichte mit dem
Merge-Requests nochmal
Applyen?
Bin ich mir gerade aus dem Kopf nicht sicher.
Also ich kann mir das noch alles merken.
Ja, aber du hast doch sicherlich ähnliche Gründe
wie ich, warum du CLI verwendest, oder?
Das ist das jetzt sicherlich nicht
die
krassesten Git-Hacks aller Zeiten
waren.
Ist klar.
Aber das war ja auch nicht der Sinn und Zweck der Sache.
Aber selbst da hast du
schon Probleme bei einigen Guis.
Dass die komische Dinger machen.
Also ich könnte mir vorstellen,
wenn du
nicht wirklich dir sicher bist mit der Bedienung
von diesem UI und
die Eigenheiten kennst,
dass bei dem Punkt
Tag auschecken,
dann Commit von einem anderen Branch auswählen,
den rüber Cherry picken, wahrscheinlich schon wieder
irgendein Mist passieren kann.
Also ich habe überhaupt keine guten Erfahrungen
und auch nicht gute Erfahrungen
mit Leuten gemacht,
die Git-Guis verwenden.
Die haben übelsten Blödsinn
committet. Ich habe da auch schon Leute gesehen,
die haben rebased auf irgendwas Falsches
und da hatte ich ein Merge-Request mit 850
Commits drin.
Das ist kein Witz.
850 Commits
und die haben den Merge-Request erstellten,
sich nicht gefragt, warum da so viel drin ist.
Einen Überblick über alle Branches
zu machen, okay. Also ich meine,
du kannst Git-Branch machen, dann siehst du,
was du lokal hast. Du kannst Git-Branch
Branch-R machen, dann siehst du, was du noch
Remote hast und dann machst
ein Grab nach deinem Kürzel oder wie du den Kram
benennst und das...
Ich meine, ja, wenn man irgendwie
150 Branches parallel von sich hat,
aber wir hatten in unserem Repro
bestimmt konstant
150 Branches,
also mit allen Features und so dabei, manchmal auch ein paar
Langläufer, da hatte ich nie Schmerzen,
das über CLI zu machen.
Oder wahrscheinlich sogar mehr, weil die meisten
Leute ihre alten Sachen nicht gelöscht haben. Wahrscheinlich
hatten wir irgendwie 5000 oder so.
Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt nichts übersehen.
Ja, das kenne ich.
Ja, darfste.
Das kenne ich. Ja, das haben wir sogar
aus Spaß
ein paar Mal schon verwendet.
Okay.
Alles klar. Gut.
Bettgeteim, Leute. Ich gehe jetzt pennen.
Wir sehen uns die Tage.
Vielleicht schon morgen. Bis dann. Macht's gut.
See you.